auf gehts
aber was gucken
oh ha ha nur leute ja ich habe gestern oder vorgestern
warte mal das muss ich mal kurz lesen witzig ich habe doch noch ich habe doch noch gestern
oder vorgestern habe ich doch erzählt dass mich hetzner mal sponsoren sollte ich mache
einfach so viel werbung für die und ich habe gerade meine emails geguckt mir hat am freitag
jemand von von der hetzner marketing abteilung geschrieben ob wir uns nicht mal über sponsoren
unterhalten wollen lustiger zufall ich habe jetzt die letzten tage weil ich so viel kopfweh hatte
nicht in die mails geguckt wenn du interesse hast schreibt mir einfach oder ruft an ich
ich schreibe ich schreibe excellent hier demnächst gibt es demnächst gibt es hetzner stonks werbung
live an und nein nein ganz bestimmt nicht aber das nice da machen wir da machen wir
unten einfach so ein so ein halbtransparentes ding hin und ich mache ab und zu ein bisschen
sehr laut und dann gucken wir mal was bei rauskommt ich hoffe die merken nicht dass meine account
auf den fake namen registriert ist weil ich habe kein bock wenn ich den kram ausversehen
meinem stream liege dass ich meine adresse und name liege deswegen habe ich mich ja mit
irgendeinem blödsinn ich einen fake kram angemeldet ich glaube ich heiß peta wubbel
oder so bei etzer wubble wubble peta wubble kann schon sein ich bin mal gespannt ich bin
mal gespannt was die was die vorhaben ich muss euch ehrlich sagen so auf sag mal so
so viele ressourcen brauche ich net dass ich das lohnt mal gucken mal gucken gucken was
wir machen ich bin mir noch gar nicht sicher ob die festgestellt haben schon dass ich weil
die haben explizit nur wegen dem stream geschrieben ich bin gar nicht ob die mit weiß gar nicht
ob die mitgekriegt haben dass ich auch noch ein youtube channel mit fast 300.000 abos
habe weil ich habe da auch keine schmerzen dort irgendwie placement zu machen für was
was ich gut finde warum nicht ich meine ich benutze den kram seit jahren warum soll ich
warum soll ich und ich finde es gut warum soll ich dafür keine werbung machen hey max ich
brauche unbedingt deine hilfe excellent ich war mal kurz hier den den dance pepe weg ihr
wisst ja hier krasses hassymbol wieder im stream eigentlich nicht guck mal eigentlich
gar nicht guck mal ich hab wenn du die letzten wenn die wenn das letzte das allerletzte video
darfst jetzt dazu nicht als beispiel nehmen das guckt das war mir klar dass es keiner
mehr guckt aber die aufrufe sind messen pock guck dir das mal an das ist anteilmäßig
extrem viel wenn du überlegst das sind ja quasi in den drittel oder so die das die
das regelmäßig gucken oder viertel in viertel die das regelmäßig gucken teilweise natürlich
auch ein bisschen mehr das ist das ist eigentlich anteilmäßig ziemlich viel mein klar gibt's
klar gammeln da auch genug abo leichen rum das ist aber halt liegt in der natur der sache
wenn man das schon zehn jahre macht ja die musik passt übrigens nicht zum bild lull
ray channel legends ja ray channel legends die haben schon mehrfach mehr ich guck mal
warte mal ich guck mal kurz in die mails noch mal rein ob wieder ray channel legends dabei
ist die sind eigentlich immer am start allerdings nicht selbst sondern über irgendeine agentur
die dann sagt wir haben ein tolles neues sponsoring angebot für dich unser unser partner ray
channel legends möchte was kaut ok also ich lese ich lese jetzt mal vor was wir was wir
so so exzellentes haben also werbung für spiele 89 facebook benachrichtigungen dazu
kann ich ja wirklich bloß sagen da gucke ich eh nicht mal rein also lasst mal kurz
rein was was haben die achten 998 facebook benachrichtigungen presse keys für irgendwie
steam games ok ne square enix standard werbung ich bin immer noch begeistert wieviel wieviel
blödsinnige sachen ich kriege wohl ich jahre lang nichts gemacht habe
diesmal ist gar nichts großartiges großartiges dabei in form von china werbung oder so hat
wieder geschrieben der schreibt auch öfters mal und pavl das nein ich will jetzt keine
leute aus polen die heißen wirklich so in den mails die schreibt die beiden schreiben
öfters pavl und pjotr schreiben öfters mails das ist von irgend so einer werbe agentur
so ah hier hier sind wir wieder ich wusste reach out range channel legends sponsoring
wo bloß die dürfen nicht fehlen die sind jedes mal drin wenn ich in die mails gucke
da sind sie wieder hallo ein seika from noise das schon wieder die hatten die hatten wir
doch die haben wir doch schon mal wanted to present you with a new pc sponsorship please
find detail details below ok mal gucken wie viel geld sie bezahlen für rachelle legends
also mobile turn based rpg now available moment moment was rate shadow legends gibt es jetzt
auch für den pc ernsthaft das gibt es jetzt auch für den bonnie oder wir bleiben ja vor
nix verschont pains jam warum hat das überhaupt so gut warum hat dieses spiel so gute bewertung
kann man das ding fack das gibt es jetzt auf dem pc ok wir bleiben echt von nix verschont
jetzt vorbei für den meck auch ok also requirements requirements also 2 stunden stream wollen
sie haben plus ein social media post und banner overlay für über den kompletten stream ok
base pay ja 840 dollar ok hängt davon ab wie viele leute sich das downloaden und dann
gibt es mehr die die scheißen auch die kohle irgendwie oder wobei man halt sagen muss das
letzte mal was mehr das letzte haben wir nur über 1000 gab ich glaube das schwankt
immer welche agentur anfragt ok und wenn es 45 leute von euch installieren kriege ich
noch mal 240 euro dollar 70 installs zusätzlich 300 what the fack ok ja leute rate shadow legends
nein hört mal auf den scheiß mache ich nicht können vergessen wirklich mache ich nicht
so crap ok weißt du eigentlich nicht immer so genau je nachdem manche schreiben wo bloß
dann weiß ich leute die schreiben hey max die wissen zumindest dass ich max heißt was
im endeffekt heißt die haben sich das ein bisschen umgeguckt und die wissen wahrscheinlich
dass ich beides habe ansonsten am schlimmsten sind die die sowas schreiben wie hello content
creators oder sowas da hast du keine ahnung ja aber da bezahlen die ja auch sonst nicht
so viel wenn es irgendwas ff was auch immer ok also was will der umut zeigt man ja hey
max ich brauche unbedingt er ich kriege von einem iran warte ich mach mal kurz die musik
ein bisschen leiser dann bin ich noch mal was anderes ja exzellent das kann ticken lauter
sein so zeig mal her ey max ich brauche unbedingt deine hilfe ich kriege von meinem internet
provider 12 feste ip adressen über einen warnport per pp es geht jetzt auch wusste
ich gar nicht ich würde gerne jede ip adresse einen privaten ip bereich zuweisen kannst
du dich ja was du willst so eins zu eins natt machen oder was oder du willst nee du willst
du willst du willst sagen dass leute aus diesem ip bereich diese externe ip verwenden sollen
beim ins internet gehen oder was ja im prinzip genau das der subnetting allein bringt dir
nix du musst ja gucken dass das ordentlich maskieren sprich dass du die absender ip austauscht
sonst kommst du ja nicht ins internet wenn du einfach nur das irgendwie rausroutest
dann hast du als absender ip eine interne ip und das funktioniert nicht du musst das
schon nacken also ich hab das noch nie gemacht auf mikrotik ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass das geht das sind relativ basic geschichten das habe ich aber noch nicht gemacht why entry
level jobs aren't entry level ok warum will und was gehts ah es ist werbung für irgendwas
excellent oder nicht sah aus wie ein werbevideo wenn ich das erste sehe wenn ich den ersten
link sehe ok exquisite 1 zu 1 natt ist ziemlich einfach dann hast du eine interne ip und eine
externe ip ja mache ich die beste entscheidung die ich je getroffen habe ich bin mir nicht
sicher was ich als nächstes video machen soll leute auf youtube ich habe also es haben
ich ja viele nach diesem teilzeit thema gefragt und ich habe ja auch vor einer weile gesagt
ich mache mal ein video ein ja home office fazit das zusammen verbinden ist ein bisschen
passt nicht so genau zusammen aber auf der anderen seite ich könnte mir auch wieder
ein reingaming bezogenes video machen zumal mir leute zumal mir auf twitter hat einer
recht gutes die die star wars battlefield wie heißt das noch mal bettel von zwei war
das video geschickt 15 minuten und ich wollte mich mal über games auslassen die mit ultra
viel halb gepusht so ente zum beispiel gepusht wurden und halt so dead on arrival sind gab
ja gab ja ein paar mein ente ist wohl das aushängeschild bettel viel fünf als auch
nicht allzu lange gemacht für das dass das ja in service game geben sollte mit über
jahre support weiß ich nicht genau was was ich als nächstes für ein video machen soll
wenn ich kann sehe ich habe jetzt relativ viel über sachen von der arbeit erzählt ich
könnte mal ein bisschen ein bisschen über über gaming sachen wieder erzählen ja bettel
von zwei nicht wirklich bettel von zwei war dead als es rausgekommen ist und wurde dann
wiederbelebt gerätzt quasi video vorschlag was verdient ein maschinenbauingenieur weiß
ich ob das ob das so spannend ist nee habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert das soll ja ja
habe ich jetzt schon öfter gehört das soll gar nicht mal so schlecht sein deswegen verstehe
ich auch nicht warum die ausgerechnet jetzt wurde es die leute wieder spielen es kein
anderer star wars game gibt das eingestellt haben ich habe ns karbon gelesen habe ich
gedacht ok hat jetzt irgendwie einer nen nintendo gemodet excellent kennst du eine gute
low power plattform in die man eine gpu packen kann ja die das wo ich mal nass mitgebaut
habe geht auf jeden fall ich weiß ich ob das so sinnvoll ist zu meinen falls du meinen
willst eher nicht na ich habe so ein so ein so ein sieben watt idle low power intel ding
es hat nen 2 pci express zweifach das ist jetzt halt vielleicht nicht unbedingt für
super krasses computing auf der grafikkade mit gpu unterstützung du meinst dass die
leute dort dann irgendwie über die gpu was ausrechnen lassen können ja der preis champ
geht übrigens wieder ich habe gestern neu gestartet da war ein bisschen kaputt der hatte
nur noch einen shop drin aber jetzt ist er wieder am start es sieht halt aktuell wirklich
so bitter aus ja das ist übrigens die unattraktivste cpu die ist natürlich lieferbar und die andere
ist halt ultra teuer so was gucken wir uns jetzt an zeige ich mal her ich habe übrigens
gar nicht so viele videos im vorfeld aufgemacht weil ich bin nicht so viel ich bookmark mir
über die woche immer so ein bisschen videos die man gucken konnte und ich habe diesmal
nichts gebucht mag ich habe einfach mal wild auf der startseite bis auf eins auf der auf
der startseite rumgeklickt ich habe noch ein bisschen kopf aber es ist besser als ich
bin guter ding in der stich so ganz normal in aufnehmen kann und striemsohren arbeiten
gehen kann also noch mal rein würdest du meinen wenn es sich lohnen würde ja also wenn
sich lohnen würde mit vertretbaren aufwand dann würde ich meinen warum nicht aber ich
weiß nicht ob sich lohnt ich glaube eher nicht oh nein omg aber eine zusage von einem super
betrieb für fachinformatik ausbildungen aus acht du scheiß kann er mal für fachinformatiker
anwendungsentwicklung ausbildung aber die machen nur c++ und ich hasse c++ kann ich
gar nicht verstehen ich finde c++ geil und ich hasse ja trotzdem nehmen oder riskieren
wenn am ende ein platz ist ganz einfach aber das war jetzt ich mag c++ auch nicht ja ich
weiß nicht ob du dir zufälligerweise den stream von gestern gesehen hast wie der titel
war ich würde das machen also wenn du wenn du sagst dass es ein super betrieb dann würde
ich da hingehen warum nicht ich würde das annehmen also wenn du wenn du sagst es ist
ein super betrieb da musste irgendwie zu dem schluss gekommen sein dass es ein super betrieb
ist dann würde ich dann würde ich auch c++ machen ich meine du lernst ja trotzdem was
und ganz ehrlich wenn du wenn du ernsthaft das durchhält drei jahre c++ pur und ich
damit gut auskennst dann bist du froh wenn du danach was anderes machen kannst und also
du hast dann was gelernt kennst dich aus und du hast den ausblick eventuell mal eine bessere
programmier sprachen zu verwenden kann ja auch motivation sein oder aber du bist nach
drei jahren so versaut mit c++ dass du c++ sogar gut findest ich habe gehört es soll
leute geben die mögen wirklich c++ und es sind leute die sind nicht im c++ cremium die
mögen das ernsthaft es ist mir absolut unverständlich wie man c++ mögen kann aber aber es gibt
wirklich leute die mögen das ich glaube das liegt daran die haben sich lang genug gequält
mit c++ dass sie sich nicht eingestehen wollen dass die zeit ja eigentlich total scheiße
war und deswegen reden sie sich das gut das sind die leute die sich damals umgefangen
die sind die sich damals eine playstation 3 gekauft haben und dann festgestellt haben
der xbox 360 multiplayer ist viel besser und hat online auf youtube gegangen sind und die
leute angeflemmt haben scheiß wixbox playstation beste weil sie eigentlich erkannt haben der
online multiplayer auf der xbox ist besser aber sie wollten sich nicht eingestehen dass
sie sich das falsche gekauft haben ich glaube so ungefähr ist das leute die ja die die
c++ geil finden ja also ich würde ich würde da hingehen also wenn du sagst das ist ein
super betrieb dann würde ich jetzt sagen c++ ist nicht so das ding ich würde es auch
nehmen ja echt zeigt mal her nice hasch probiere ich jetzt aus was nicht drucken search nice
hasch ok was muss man da eingeben habe ich noch nie verwendet try mining no nice wo kann
man das ausrechnen check your profits das ist doch bestimmt jebait oder enter hardware
moment ich glaube die seite ist nicht für dark theme gedacht flashbang leute bäm currency
euro was kostet der strom in deutschland so strom kosten privat ich weiß nicht was ich
dafür bezahlt ehrlich gesagt 0,28 ok warum ist das strom bei uns eigentlich so teuer
im kokonaland kostet das irgendwie gar nix marvin hast du mal ein video hast du da gucken
wir uns erst zum ersten mal wenn es ein gutes video ist erst mal link da gucken wir uns
zum ersten mal pc welt video an pc welt ok ich habe 1080 ti calculate also dafür lohnt
es sich ehrlich gesagt nicht also für 3 euro am tag ist es mir glaube ich nicht wert mein
pc 24 sieben laufen lassen man kann auch auf ok was macht er denn wenn man auf dem
reisen meint gar nix ok grafika da ist immer noch beste was ist wenn ich in 30 90 habe
guck mal da 30 90 30 90 exquisite wie sieht es mit einer 30 80 aus 120 28 ok das lohnt
es sich wirklich also meiner zu meinen lohnt sich lohnt sich echt nicht aber warum kaufen
die leute das eigentlich ich meine guck mal du musst dann mal angenommen das verstehe
ich nicht guck mal mal auf die jetzt eine 30 90 fürs meinen was ja mit dafür verantwortlich
ist dass das so wenig du musst ja du bekommst also in zehn tagen ok lass mal kurz ausrechnen
sind wir mal großzügig runden das mal auf also 9 euro am tag das heißt du bekommst
im monat 270 euro das heißt du musst ungefähr 7 monate meinen am stück dass du den preis
nur von der grafikkarte wieder raushast profit ja da haben wir doch richtig gerechnet
du kriegst so fünf euro am tag ja aber fünf euro am tag dafür dass du den ganzen rechnen
die ganze zeit laufen lässt ich weiß nicht ob das so sinnvoll ist warum sag mal meine
blöde frage meine blöde frage warum ist denn noch keiner auf die idee gekommen in
die wüste rechner mit solar panels zu stellen gibt es doch muss es doch schon geben
so staubig in island also das heißt ich kann mir in island einen server kaufen und dort
meinen oder was island meinen aha der krypto könig ihre erste meinung von für bitcoins
alles klar unterwasser das ja wie microsoft eben war es doch noch weniger ändert sich
das permanent oder was ich mein 10 euro am tag achso das ist 0, das hat sich gesettet
ok also in deutschland lohnt sich irgendwie weiß ich nicht interessant ok war schnell
durch scrollen chat das wäre eine gute idee ja bitcoin mining auf dem auf der hmx was
zum teufel ist eine hmx 3 pc welt alter ich habe ich glaube ich habe die letzten fünf
jahre kein pc welt video mehr geguckt ok das muss das gucken wir uns gleich mal an was
höllen was hmx ist ne oder höllen masch stimmt stimmt der kram von der pc welt diese
diese ultra teuren rechner hießen immer so er höllen masch kann nur von der pc welt
kommen chip filter ist hier chip hat bestimmt auch so was es wusste dir dass es mal eine
zeit gab wo man wo man die wo man die zeitschrift an sich tatsächlich lesen konnte und es recht
interessant war das ist leider schon seit 15 jahren oder so vorbei aber das war gar
nicht mal so schlecht ok das stimmt aber dann kann ich nicht
weiter meinen ne habe ich nicht mitgekriegt irgendwann ja gut wenn man das jetzt also
wenn du das sicher voraussagen kannst wenn du das sicher voraussagen kannst dann würde
ich sagen auf gehts kaufen
das geht aber in letzter zeit schon krass ab war das nicht erst noch irgendwie bei 30.000
oder so war das nicht erst noch bei 30.000 gestern
wurde sehr krass stonks gibt es irgendwie guten kurzverlauf so stonks ja
im december 15.000 da haben die leute noch gesagt habe ich jetzt kaufen soll nicht krasser
scheiß ordentlich massiv stonks
bitcoin kletter erstmal über 60.000 also für alle die den kram gekauft haben und
todeln bestes wort immer noch die haben jetzt fett money gemacht
hallo gibt es einen chart
das ging ja richtig krass ab und hier hier kann ich mich hier sind sie alle schon ausgeflippt
so nach dem allzeit hoch und ab jetzt geht es nur noch runter und es ging auch ein bisschen
runter und dann ging es anfangen ist ja so
es geht da richtig ab da ist
kommt mal hier aber sag mal so wenn man das jetzt sieht sagt man sagt man easy hätte
man ja hätte man ja kaufen muss die sache ist die was ich letztes video schon gesagt
und bist halt nachher immer schlauer du weißt es halt nicht wenn du es wirklich wüsstest
dann wäre das ja easy ne krasser scheiß alter das geht ja mega ab
wahnsinn warum ist das eigentlich so verfolgt das irgendwie mal also warum geht das seit
diesem jahr noch noch so richtig oder warum geht das sein ende letzten jahresvideos krass
ab
also es wundert mich ja nicht dass es schon bots gibt die analysieren was ilon mask twittert
und es dann direkt kaufen überlegt man überlegt man hätte wirklich gesagt ich scheiß drauf
ich letztes jahr war hätte ich geklaut mal letztes jahr weihnachten hätte gesagt alter
ich gönne mir einfach ein bitcoin dann hättest du das jetzt verdoppelt so über den daumen
gepeilt schon hart oder exzellent hätte man sich zu weihnachten mal ein bitcoin gegannt
ja nice ups so jetzt kommen wir mal ein paar witz
ja gut das interessiert aber kein so lang stonks gibt
das kenne ich schon das habe ich schon mal geguckt impf pass blockchain hauptsache blockchain
dabei ja irgendwann bestimmt aber wenn das halt die frage ob du vor noch kohle mit machen
kannst ohne ja das stimmt aber die die das bis jetzt am start haben und das tatsächlich
also mein also hätte ich den kram jetzt gekauft vor was weiß ich wie viele jahre ich glaube
spätestens jetzt hätten würde ich verkaufen und easy easy millionär ja ja das das tatsächlich
ja ja total viel da gab es doch den typ der irgendwie seine festplatte von der müllhalle
holen wollte weil da gibt es noch bitcoins drauf sind
du kannst ja überhaupt nicht wirklich bestimmen was du für den strom bekommst also wo war
aber wo war denn das video jetzt ok bitcoin also leute ich habe mir noch nie einen pc
welt video also doch habe ich schon habe ich schon stimmt nicht letzten fünf jahre kein
pc welt video angeguckt ich weiß nicht ob das cringe ist
oder du machst das wie cristiano ronaldo und meinst monero auf deiner webseite
stimmt die stimme ist schon cringe naja komm sei jetzt mal nicht so gemein
jetzt haben professionelle minor den grafikkartenmarkt quasi leer gekauft aber die beiden schätzchen
hier die zwei msi rtx 3090 gaming x trio die haben sie nicht bekommen
oh nein wir für uns für euch für die hmx ach du scheiße ist das video testen wir mal
wie gut sich das system zum meinung tatsächlich eignet um die hmx 3 optimal auszulasten schließe
ich mich für unseren test jetzt mal an einen mining pool an und zwar nice hash der vorteil
ist dass die eine echt einfach zu benutzen nice hash die haben auch so ein demo tool
das euer system checkt und euch sagt ja gut das haben wir ja gerade abhängig vom aktuellen
bitcoin wert natürlich verdienen könnt das starte ich jetzt mal ja ok das auf die
webseite hey die webseite auf den knopf drücken das können wir auch erklär michi ein bisschen
teori zum thema kryptowährung oh nee nee hör mal auf ok das gehts praktisch in der
rechnung überhaupt nicht ich muss das vorspulen das wird zu cringe wie 32 cent pro kilowattstunde
so jetzt schauen wir mal was die hmx 3 mal 106 das schaut ordentlich was das ding weg
frisst 32 cent zahlt ihr 6 euro 96 pro tag wenn man das von den einnahmen abzieht kommt
man also auf einen reingewinn von rund 11 euro pro tag bzw 335 euro pro monat das ist eigentlich
gar nicht mal so schlecht also jetzt lassen wir mal rechnen dann habe ich nach fünf monaten
habe ich zumindest den uvp auf der anderen seite du kannst dir den rechner dann für
nichts anderes verwenden in der zwischenzeit also nach zehn monaten ist das schon refinanziert
und dann ist klar dass sehr viele gerade meinen oder was man aber noch berücksichtigen muss
eure einnahmen sind abhängig vom aktuellen bitcoin kurs der klar mit rund 42.000 euro
man hat ziemlich hoch tja jetzt jetzt ist da so weit wo sie nicht auf dem chart drauf
ist sollte er noch höher steigen verdient natürlich auch entsprechend mehr aber wenn
er runter rauscht lohnt es sich entsprechend weniger und wenn er unter die marke von ungefähr
16.400 euro fällt das haben jetzt ausgerechnet dann rutscht ihr beim mining mit der hmx 3
sogar in die miesen weil der strom dann halt teurer ist als das was ihr verdient also aufpassen
denn es ist gerade mal ein paar monate her dann stand der bitcoin kurs noch bei rund
11.000 euro also kommen wir zum fazit wenn man vom aktuellen bitcoin kurs und strompreis
aus ja gut ist klar mit der hmx 3 durch meinen per nice hash rund 335 euro im monat verdienen
aber eigentlich ist die hmx 3 ja ein gaming pc und eigentlich hoffentlich wie fast alle
gamer ist der bitcoin kurs möglichst schnell wieder fällt wir müssen einfach mehr grafikkarten
produzieren mehr geld verdienen mit mining unattraktiver und grafikkarten werden hoffentlich
endlich ich glaube da sind viele leute hin und her die wollen natürlich das grafikkarten
günstiger sind aber wenn sie mit coins haben wollen sie nicht dass der kurs fällt und
manche hudeln eh komplett ich finde dieses wort so geil die verkaufen das nie ich habe
mir den pc jetzt gar nicht angeguckt wie sah der aus ok das sieht aus wie ein 3d drucker
von der seite sonderlich geil finde ich das jetzt nett sieht aus wie ein 3d drucker
die hudelgänge ist am start so was gucken wir uns jetzt an was ist denn deines gucken
wir uns das nicht oh remember er kommt wie wisst ihr was wir gucken jetzt eine runde
entweder zwei an weiß nicht genau warum aber irgendwie ist miss jetzt da so aber habt ihr
auch das noch mal noch mal zu dieser bitcoin geschichte ich habe ich bin ja nicht so da
stammt man nicht so finanzen ist jetzt so nicht unbedingt das gebiet was mich großartig
interessiert aber so ein bisschen du kommst ja nicht wirklich daran vorbei dass man so
ein bisschen was von bitcoin mitkriegt auch so seit seit den letzten drei jahren oder
so würde ich sagen und jedes mal wenn es dann wieder so neues krasses kurs hoch gibt
dann denke ich mir immer so kurz er hätte den scheiß vor drei jahren gekauft so ein
drei jahren später neues kurz hoch er hätte den graber vor drei jahren gekauft letztendlich
du bist halt immer schlauer nachher und ich weiß nicht ob das man kann sich halt aus der
vergangenheit da nichts wirklich ableiten also sprich nur weil es jetzt die letzten
drei jahre übers abgegangen ist wenn man es wüsste dass das jetzt auf 100k landet klar
easy easy kauf aber
warum willst du ethereum wie sieht denn da der kurs aus
das ja krass guck mal das ist auch von das ist ähnlich ne guck mal das ist auch ab ende
2000 ist das auch übelst abgegangen genauso bitcoin was macht eigentlich was macht eigentlich
dogecoin das macht so gekleid aktuell so die dogecoin juck naja alter fucking dogecoin
naja also ich guck jetzt ne runde mw2 ganzen ganzen stonksthema
ja weg zeig mal her ja dogecoin stimmt es hat auch hat hat der elon ja auch kurz erwähnt
und seitdem ging es auch ab ich installiere mir einfach so einen elon mask bot der guckt
was der typ auf twitter schreibt und ist dann instant kauft natt typ ja das ist halt 2021
colorflute immer noch ein ding was ich nicht verstehe ok zeig mal her komm ne runde mw2
geht jetzt
oh nein
Es ist der mp5? Ich kann mich an die Waffen gar nicht mehr richten. War das die mw2 mp5?
Ich habe es gehört. Ich habe es links im Ohr gerade Claymore klicken gehört.
Klar wirst du dich heute der mw2 aufregen. Ich habe damals schon gesagt mw2 besteht komplett aus random shit.
Ich finde mw2 ehrlich gesagt heute immer noch nicht sonderlich geil. Es war aber, ich fand Black Ops 1 deutlich besser.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, der Bullshit in Black Ops 1 hielt sich halbwegs in Grenzen. Aber ansonsten, ich bin immer noch der Meinung.
Cort 4, 5 und Black Ops 1, das war vom Bullshit Faktor im Multiplayer noch das geringste Übel. Vielleicht noch Black Ops 2.
Ja, das hat keiner verwendet. Konnte man nicht den Kram rerollen? Nee, das war in Black Ops 1. In Black Ops 1 kann ich mich daran erinnern.
Ich habe mit dem Friseur mal zusammen, haben wir versucht, man konnte drei Care Packages irgendwie droppen.
Care Package, Valkyrie Missiles und noch irgendwas. Man konnte drei Sachen droppen und die konnte man alle rerollen.
Und da haben wir mal versucht ein Game zu erspielen, wo wir nur rerollt haben auf High Kill Streaks. Das hat funktioniert.
Also du konntest dann quasi einen Chopper gerne so nach dem Otto kriegen. War aber nicht in Black Ops 1, doch oder?
Das war glaube ich Black Ops 1, wo man rerollen konnte.
Was ist mit dem Typ da hinten los? Warum steht er einfach rum und schießt?
Nicht richtig. In your face Shotgun, jawoll.
Ist es normal, dass es so schnell weg geht?
Hä, die Flashbang ging noch, oder bringe ich die Flashbang jetzt durcheinander? Ging die nur so kurz und auf instant wieder weg?
Da leckt es, ja so war das normalerweise.
Ah, weggesprayt, jawoll.
Ah ok, es leckt. Es leckt oder es ruckelt, eins von beiden. Ich würde mal sagen in dem Fall, es leckt und dadurch weist das Game nicht weiter und deswegen ruckelt es.
Alter, ich Messe rumgelegge.
Stimmt, die Care Packages konnten ja damals noch auf dem Dach landen. Da konntest du die Leute übelst trollen, wenn irgendwie ein Chopper gerne auf dem Dach lag.
Nee, das leckt krass. Das erschlägt ihn jetzt gleich.
Oh, was das? Nein, nein, nein.
Die klauen eben jetzt alle den Chopper gunner und den Harry und das ganze Zeug.
Nein, das ist fies, Alter.
Ok, da kannst du Kills farmen. Da kannst du Kills farmen as fuck.
Und das eine liegt, was ist denn das? Ist das ein Air Strike? Der hinter der Mauer liegt? Oder hinter dem Zaun? Das ist ein Air Strike, glaube ich.
Ranger Akimbo, ja. Aber eigentlich der richtig krasse Bait. Den Kram hinter die Absperrung droppen, alle kommen so hin gerannt, weil sie das sehen auf der Map und du kannst so bashen, Alter.
Oh, nicht nachladen. Ok, das war äußerst risikoreich, ja. Darüber zu rennen, ohne zu gucken.
Kann man das creppen durch den Zaun? Nee, fuck.
Meistens ist ja in dem Care Package nix gescheites drin gewesen. Da war vielleicht ULV oder irgendwie ein Counter-ULV oder...
Was war denn der sinnloseste Killstreak in MW2? Anti-Air oder war das Black Ops 1?
Oh, der Shotgun-Dude. Stimmt, du konntest Munition troppen im... Stimmt, das ging auch, ja, genau.
Die Sentry-Gun war glaub... Ja, kann sein. Ich kann mir das nicht mehr merken, genau. Alter.
Das ist aber... Aber im Prinzip mal ehrlich, mit sowas hat's angefangen, ne. Dass du halt so Random-Kack drin hast.
Ich mein, MW2 war kompletter Random-Kack, wenn du's so willst. Also das war ja so random, das Game. Du konntest zwei Meter grad auslaufen, bist random von irgendwas gestorben.
Aber die Care Package, sowas ist da drin, dass Leute, die halt wirklich mega, mega, mega scheiße sind, auch mal nen Shotgun erkriegen.
Da, drei Kills. Wo war ein Care Package mit Hardline? Drei Kills? Vier Kills?
Drei Kills. War das rerollen? War das rerollen? Das war Black Ops 1, oder? Ziemlich sicher. Ich kann mich doch dran erinnern, dass ich mit dem Friseur rerollt hab.
Oh, oh nein. Last Stand. Fuck you, Last Stand. MW1 hat das MW3? Wirklich? Moment, das muss ich jetzt nachgucken. Black Ops 1 reroll Care Package.
Bei Hardline Pro, genau, genau. Hardline Pro rerollen, so sah's aus. Ich weiß nämlich noch, wir standen dann rum und haben dann diese, du konntest alles rerollen, nicht nur Care Package.
Du konntest deinen Valkyrie Missiles droppen, deinen Sentry Gun konntest du rerollen, alles, was getroppt wurde als Package. Und da haben wir, ich weiß auch, Tage lang haben wir einfach nur sinnlos rumgestanden, Low Kill Streaks und haben Care Packages getroppt und rerollt, bis was Gutes rausgekommen ist.
Und wenn du das zu zweit gemacht hast, bilde mir sogar ein, du konntest sogar Packages rerollen von jemand anderem, aber da bin ich mir nicht mal hundertprozentig sicher. Nee, nee, ich glaub das ging nicht. Nee, ich glaub das ging nicht. Oder? Ging das vielleicht am Anfang am Samstag gefixt?
Ah, G18 Akimbo, beste. Wenn man nicht weiß, was man nehmen soll, im Game als Pistel. Dafür war G18 alleine kacke.
Farmas rote Tigerstreifen. Das durftest du ja wenn du nicht Ello Tricks bis damals nicht spielen, da kamen ja die Fanboys, haben geflamed, warum du Farmas mit roten Tigerstreifen spielst.
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaghhh yeah, Alter, das parall pufft immer nicht.
Okay, wir haben es. Lass uns gehen. Mein Teamkamerad ist in dem Prozess gestorben. Aber, äh, sollen wir meine Teamkameraden hier schämen? Schämen sie den Teamkameraden. Schämen sie den Teamkameraden, Jungs.
Genieße ein paar Care Packages.
Würdest du?
Alter, das hat mich immer aufgeregt in dem Game. Wenn du gemessert wurdest. Dieser Messer-Sound.
Nee, Marvin. Ich hatte auch mehr Stunden in Battlefield.
Panic Knife, ja. Aber das war damals richtig die Pest mit Panic Knife, ne? Du hattest Leute, äh, Marvin Cryptech, du hattest Leute, das hast du richtig gesehen, die haben, sobald sie beschossen wurden, Knife, Knife, Knife. Einfach mal, einfach mal, wenn sie nicht wussten, von wo sie beschossen wurden, einfach knife, knife. Du, das waren die Leute, wenn du die beschossen hast, von einer Weile, von, von, von, von, von, von ein bisschen weiter weg, haben die einfach geschossen.
Da hast du immer so gesehen, bam, Luftmesser, bam, Luftmesser. Die haben sich das so angewöhnt, weil das hat funktioniert.
Kommando Knife. Das Beste, das Beste, das Beste, um Leute zu ärgern in dem Game, war immer noch, ähm, Marathon Lightweight Kommando und dann das Pistol, das Pistol Knife. Dieses, dieses Fast Knife.
Wisst ihr noch, wo man, man konnte Knife und, und Pistole, so zusammen ausruhen, hat er dann schneller, schneller gemessert. Tack the Tackle-Messer, irgendwie so. Und da konntest du echt rumrennen und, und alle schnetzeln.
Schneiber Dude. Ich seh, ich seh den Typ überhaupt nicht. Oh, oh. Der, der Schneiber Dude, Alter. Das ist der schlechteste Sniper, Ever. Okay, vielleicht nicht Ever, aber, naja.
Noch besser die P90 Akimbo. Das stimmt, da war auch irgendwas.
Noob to the repackage. Ja, das war ja die Noob-Variante, genau.
Es gab, im Prinzip war MW2 ein Game, was zum größten Teil, wo viel, also sag mal so, wo man zum größten Teil den Spaß draus gezogen hat, dass man andere Leute zum Raging gebracht hat. Das Game war halt einfach so krass random, du konntest das gar nicht ohne auszurasten ernsthaft spielen.
Ich kann mich noch an den Solution erinnern, damals, der, der hat ja permanent rumgeschrien, wenn er MW2 gespielt hat. Ist der, schreit er heute eigentlich immer noch so viel rum? Ich weiß, er macht öfters Warzone-Streams, ich hab da ab und zu mal reingeguckt, da, da war es halbwegs normal.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob der immer noch so rumschreit wie damals in MW2, aber MW2 war auch echt abfuckt, was das angeht.
Ich glaube so viele Spiele schon hab ich in MW2 letztendlich gar nicht, weil es mich immer so aufgeregt hat, dass ich nicht länger spielen konnte als fünf Runden am Stück. Tango Sucker.
Ey, was klaust du einfach? Was klaust du einfach hier die Predator? Anzeige ist raus.
Oh, Lack. Huge Lack.
Eigentlich ist es richtig, eigentlich ist es richtig big brain die Care Packages liegen zu lassen.
Guck mal, du kannst sie einfach easy in the ass shooten, weil die versuchen Care Packages zu grabben, obwohl da nur Mist drinne ist und sich gar nicht lohnt meistens.
Noob Magnet, ja echt so. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Chopper Gunner ist oder ein AC One, da würde ich es mal ausprobieren.
Aber sag mal, eine New Care Package droppen ging nicht, ne? Hab ich auch nie gesehen.
Ja, das war ja legendär damals, diese ganzen Trick Shot Geschichten. Wer erinnert sich noch auf High Rise Last Nice?
High Rise Last Nice, Multigo 990, danke für den Sub.
Last Nice.
Und dann haben sie eine halbe Stunde gekreiselt um sich drum herum und gestunt mit Flash Nades.
Damit sie irgendeinen nice Trick Shot treffen.
Genau, und dann vom Kran runter gesprungen. Am besten noch vom Kran runter gesprungen und nebenbei diesen komischen Search and Destroy Laptop in der Hand.
Kennt ihr das noch? Oder Leather Jump Claymore Switch und solche Dinge? Da gab es so abgetreten Schwachsinn.
Die hatten ja auch alle irgendwelche komischen Namen.
Eigentlich müsstest du den Emergency Airtrop da jetzt hinsetzen und einfach hier oben Head Glitch campen und alles abknallen was an den Emergency Airtrop geht.
Wow, es hat geruckelt. Ammo? Nee. Counter UAV Predator, Alter.
Ich glaube, ich würde es echt liegen lassen und die ganzen Typen abfarben.
Oh nein.
Jetzt wusstest du, dass er links ist, weil er links das Package aufgehoben hat.
Genau, Trick Shots waren, man musste möglichst viel machen, während man sich dreht.
Generell musstest du, wenn du den Nuke zündest, dich drehen und in die Luft messern, ansonsten war die nicht legit.
Es hat schon komische Auswüchse angenommen.
Komische Züge hat es angenommen, aber irgendwie war es witzig.
In the Egg sitzt er.
Oh Claymore, wie es ruckelt.
Na gut, ohne irgendwelche Lobby Hacks kannst du das hier heute gar nicht mehr spielen.
Ihr seht ja auch, wie das laggt. Guck mal, der schießt ihn ab und das laggt eine Sekunde.
Der schießt und es dauert eine Sekunde, bis es hitet.
Ach, ich hab ganz vergessen, Leute, die Killstreaks haben ja noch gestackt für nächsten Killstreaks.
Das ist ja seit den letzten paar Teilen so, dass es nicht mehr stackt.
Ich kann mich nur noch dran erinnern, wo sie das Bild auf dem Klo entfernt haben, weil die Leute empört waren.
Kommt auf, jetzt lief der Haus. Der Haus lief jetzt, weil Chopper gunner.
Stimmt, die haben ja Vavela removed wegen dem Bild auf dem Klo.
Das kann es auch echt übertreiben.
Was für ein Bild auf dem Klo, Moment, zeige ich dir. Vavela, MB2, Toilet.
Ups, warum schreibe ich das gerade?
Painting on wall, Toilet upsets.
Ja, äh.
Erkennt man das überhaupt?
Was ist das für ein Bild, Alter, du erkennst ja gar nichts.
Moment, das ist doch nachdem es weggemacht wurde, oder?
Die haben dort von irgendeinem Arab, ach, das, das da.
Genau, genau, genau, dieser Bilderrahmen.
Also, die Mapper haben halt einfach einen Prefab, also die haben halt gerade einen Item von einer arabisch gethämten Map halt einfach genommen und in Vavela aufs Klo gehängt.
Also wer den Mappern da wirklich irgendwelche Bösartigkeit unterstellt, der hat sie nicht mehr, all meiner Meinung nach.
So, und auf dem Bilderrahmen steht, wenn man ranzoomt mit dem Sniper steht irgendwas mit Allah auf Arabisch.
Und da haben sich die Leute extrem aufgeregt, warum das auf dem Klo hängt.
Und das geht überhaupt nicht.
Und daraufhin haben die die Map entfernt erst mal, bis das gefixt wurde und das Bild weg war.
Ja, da habe ich glaube ich ein Video drüber gemacht.
Das war eines der ersten Ereignisse, wo ich mal so realisiert habe, ohne Witz, wo ich so realisiert habe, dass die Leute echt am Rad drehen immer mehr.
Und mittlerweile ist es ja normal, dass wegen jeder kleinen Scheiß das riesen Shitstorm fast aufgemacht wird.
Also unter irgendeinem Rassismusvorwurf tut es heutzutage kein Shitstorm mehr.
Das war so das erste, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Alter die Leute übertreiben aber richtig.
Und mittlerweile ist es eigentlich noch schlimmer.
Der Urvater von Cancel Culture, könnte man fast so sagen, ja.
Die haben das, ich weiß nicht wie lange die es gebraucht haben.
Also als die sich drüber aufgeregt haben über das Bild, war MW2 glaube ich schon out und Black Ops 1 angesagt.
Und ja ich glaube das hat eine Weile gedauert.
Auch bis das alles gefixt wurde.
Heutzutage würde man das nach zwei Tagen finden.
Ja wahrscheinlich, ey ohne Mist.
Also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wenn große Games rauskommen wie irgendein Call of Duty oder sowas heute.
Es gibt genug Leute, die suchen die ab, um explizit was zu finden, wo man sich öffentlich auf Social Media empören kann.
Bad Company 2, oh ich weiß ich habe schon ganz lange nicht mehr gespielt.
Battlefield 3 habe ich, Battlefield 3 habe ich jetzt recht viel gespielt in letzter Zeit.
Leider ist Venice Dead.
Das ist Venice Dead.
Okay was hat dann der Aura gekauft für 420 Euro?
Warum ist es ausgerechnet vor 20 Euro?
War das nicht gut für die Aufmerksamkeit?
Im Prinzip ist denen bei Activision alles recht was Aufmerksamkeit gibt.
Was hat er sich denn gekauft für 420?
RapeNations Euro.
Hat er ein neues Intro?
Ich habe schon lange kein Video mehr geguckt.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Der Aura hat bestimmt auch Kryptowährung.
Ein paar Videos angefangen, dass wir, ich sag mal, O11dynamic fakes oder abklatscht Produkte.
Was ist O11dynamic?
Das ist ein Gehäuse?
Aha.
O11dynamic, alles klar.
Inspirierte Produkte davon angefangen haben zu kaufen.
Das letzte Video war ein Intertec C101 oder sowas.
Das war ja eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht für den Preis.
Ach das ist das Bauergehäuse.
Okay, war natürlich nicht perfekt, hat ein paar Menge.
Wobei wir wissen ja spätestens seit unges Video mindestens eine Million in Krypto.
Ey der hat bestimmt ordentlich Kohle gemacht jetzt mit Bitcoin Stealth.
Nicht dass er es wirklich nötig hätte, aber er hat bestimmt ordentlich Kohle gemacht.
Der Krümel, Dankeschön für 3 Monate Subscriptions.
Ich glaube das war keine gute Entscheidung das zu kaufen.
Dieses Video wird präsentiert von den Corsair Hydro X Wasserkühlungskomponenten.
Die habt ihr bei mir schon öfter gesehen.
Zum Beispiel natürlich der XG7 Wasserkühlungskomponent.
Ah, ein Runde Sellout. Exquisite, exquisite Sellout.
So muss das sein.
30, 80, 30, 90 Founders Edition.
Kassenmodelle wie die Strix.
30, 90, ja gut.
Wenn du 3000 Euro ausgeben willst, was kostet...
Was sagt denn der Preischamp aktuell?
30, 90 kostet was?
Äh...
Ja.
Also im Prinzip bezahlst du gerade das Doppelte vom UVP.
Wir haben den XG7...
Easy.
...URGB Block für alle aktuellen Intel und AMD Sockel.
Dann natürlich die gute Wasserkühlungsflüssigkeit.
Die darf natürlich nicht fehlen um euer System bzw. euren Kreislauf auch zu schützen.
Dann gibt es mittlerweile sogar...
Ich dachte...
Ich dachte, da macht man einfach destilliertes Wasser rein in eine Wasserkühlung.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es da extra super destilliertes Wasser gibt.
Oder ist das wirklich besser?
Ich hab keinen Plan.
Ihr wisst, ich hab keine Wasserkühlung.
Noch nie und hab's noch nicht vor.
Und dann haben wir zum Beispiel auch noch...
Danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier.
Ey, ich hab letztens bei dir wieder reingeguckt.
Du hast wieder...
Ähm...
Irgendwas speedrunnt.
Es war glaub ich nicht Wind Waker.
Oder war es doch Wind Waker?
Ich hab letztens mal dir wieder reingeguckt und hab gesagt, ach guck mal da, er ist ja wieder on.
Genau, Donkey Kong, das war nicht Wind Waker.
Korrisionsschutz, okay.
Wind Waker und Speedrun sind mittlerweile voll abgedreht.
Ich hab da letztens mal wieder ein Video drüber geguckt.
Äh...
Wie da durchs Meer katapultiert wird, Alter.
Und so mit...
Mit 1 zu 20er Chance und sowas.
Krasser Shit, äh...
Das ist destilliertes Wasser aus dem Vatikan.
Holy Water.
Holy Des...
Holy Wasserkühlungswater, ey.
Hat der Papst persönlich gesegnet.
Falls ihr wissen wollt, was genau und wo ihr es bekommt.
Link findet ihr unten in der Beschreibung.
Hier könnt ihr zumindest mal sehen,
was ich da gekauft habe.
Und zwar steht hier dran
bei der Marke
HDYD.
Keine Ahnung.
Dadurch, dass er das vom Bildschirm abfilmt,
sieht es fast so aus, als würden sich die
Lüfter drehen, oder?
Durch die Farbfehler.
Blablabla.
Neun Lüfterposition.
Ich finde auch das Produktbild
suggeriert so ein bisschen,
dass hier neun Lüfter dabei sein sollen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Da ist so viel dabei.
Bei dieser Produktbeschreibung.
Und ja, wir sehen
die Sachen, die da vorgeschlagen werden,
die sehen ja alle so ein bisschen... Das sollte, ohne Scheiß,
wenn der Vatikan mit der Zeit gehen würde,
dann würden die, ähm...
Wasserkühlungs... äh...
Ich denk's, ähm...
Gesegnetes Wasser für Wasserkühlung
oder irgendwas verkaufen. Da gibt's bestimmt genug
Leute, ähm, oder
Papst Badewasser.
Da gibt's bestimmt genug Leute, die kaufen das.
Weihwasser
für Wasserkühlung. Und,
und, und, du kannst hier noch, ähm...
Genau, Papst Badewasser
geht auch noch.
Was diese
ATX... Was macht Bell denn viel
eigentlich gerade so?
Wo wir gerade bei
Gammagirl Badewasser sind.
Außer, außer schlechte
Porns machen.
Da kann man auch sehen, was für einen horrenden Preis
ich dafür bezahlt habe. Boah!
Alter! Wenn ich es bestellt habe, war's glaube ich
sogar ein bisschen mehr, um die 360.
Ja, ihr seht, am 4. Januar
gekauft, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Hat jetzt sehr, sehr lange gedauert, bis es da war.
Und hier haben wir jetzt diesen Haufen.
Es ist wirklich ein Haufen. Und was
mich schon mal wundert schon wieder,
also das Teil, was ich hier habe... Das ist typisch...
Das machen die aber gerne.
Das hatte ich auch schon öfters bei China-Verpackungen,
dass die einen Karton haben
sie nochmal komplett mit Band
oder Folie umwickelt. Ich hab auch nie verstanden
warum.
Aber das hast du bei China-Sachen ganz oft,
dass das nochmal komplett in Kleber
oder Folie gewickelt. Warum? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich trauen die ihren eigenen
Kartons nicht.
Es gibt jetzt eine Belldelfin-Tastatur.
Ernsthaft? Die müssen wir uns holen.
Es gibt echte Tastatur?
Das Belldelfin-Keyboard!
Oh, exzellent!
Das haben wir gebraucht!
Das muss das...
Ja. Also...
Hätte ich das jetzt nicht gewusst,
dass es gibt, da hätte mir echt was gefehlt.
Das kommt offensichtlich aus China. Also ist ja klar.
Ich meine, alle Computergehäuse heutzutage werden
nicht in China produziert. Das ist jetzt
keine wirkliche Überraschung. Was an so was
absolut nervig ist, ist allerdings, wenn man bei Amazon
was bestellt, Amazon Deutschland... Damit wirst du
zum Pro... Nein, nein, nein, Leute.
Zum Pro-Gamer kann man nur mit
einem Controller werden. Und das wisst ihr ganz genau.
Nämlich mit dem...
Mit dem Fanatec Headshot Controller.
Die Maus! Die macht mich jedes Mal
fertig. Sieht aus wie ein Fahrrad-Ständer
mit Schloss dran.
High-Speed-Pad. Zusammen ein
unschlagbares Team. Die Maus ist
super ergonomisch und lässt sich an jede
Handform anpassen. Das sorgt auch
in langen Gamer-Sessions für
ermüdungsfreies Spielen. Sieht so schlecht aus!
Sechs Maus-Buttons und ein 5-Wege Steuerrad sorgen
dafür, dass sie ihre Spielfigur
auch in heißen Gefechten im Griff haben.
Die Plasmaglide-Maus-Füße
sorgen zusammen mit dem High-Speed-Pad
für minimale Haft- und Gleitreibung,
für schnelles, präzises Zielen
im Spiel.
Das leichte Kabel kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert
nicht in die Quere.
Das sieht so schlecht aus!
Das sieht aus wie ein Fahrrad-Ständer!
Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben...
Oho! Krasse, enge Bildschirte!
Guckt's euch an!
Farben, Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz
machen das Spiel noch rasanter.
Profi-Gamer sind begeistert von den
Programmiermöglichkeiten für Maus und
Tastatur selbst während des Spiels.
Auch Makros lassen sich
die Plasmaglide-Maus einsetzen.
Damit sind sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen
und anderen Games der King.
Der Fanatec Headshot Controller
ist das ultimative Set für
Gamer. Und wetten, dass er
auch als Geschenk gut ankommt.
Probieren Sie es aus!
Das ist so schlecht!
Okay, jetzt gucken wir das, das andere Video weiter.
Und dann dauert es natürlich
erst mal irgendwie
acht Wochen, wo man schon denkt, ist das Ding
irgendwo verschollen? Und dann kann man hier sehen...
Also
ich muss sagen, ich habe immer bei AliExpress
mein Geld bekommen.
Oder, oder, oder, oder das, was ich
bestellt habe, ja. Aber
einmal, die war halt
echt veräppelt, ne? Ich hab irgendwie
Elektronik-Kleinkram bestellt bei AliExpress.
Und
daraufhin haben sie gesagt,
okay, wurde jetzt versandt. Und
nach ein paar Wochen wurde die AliExpress-
Bestellung markiert auf, als ist eingetroffen.
Hab ich gesagt, Leute, es ist nicht eingetroffen.
Laut Eurem Tracking-Link ist das Ding
immer noch in China. Und
daraufhin
meinten sie, ja, ja, ja, sie haben mir
den falschen Tracking-Link geschickt.
Hat sich aber nichts getan. Habe ich in AliExpress
Case, also
so einen Kunden-Konflikt-Lösungsfall
aufgemacht. Und
dann haben die mir einen neuen Tracking-Link geschickt
und haben mich halt veräppelt. Und es war der gleiche
Tracking-Link von vorher, der immer noch nicht richtig
funktioniert hat, und stand, dass der Kram in China ist.
Und dann haben sie rumgeheult so nach dem
Motto, oh nein, wir sollen Ihnen noch mehr
Zeit geben. Es war irgendwie acht Wochen her
oder so. Und da muss man sagen,
AliExpress entgegen
Paypal hat die ganze
Sache direkt in meinem
Sinne gelöst. Also sprich, bei
Paypal ist es so, wenn du nicht reagierst
oder nicht in einer gewissen Zeit,
dann wird das geclosed und der
Shop kriegt Recht.
Bei AliExpress ist es so, wenn du nicht
bestätigst, der Fall ist erledigt,
kriegst du dein Geld wieder.
Und ich habe instant mein Geld wieder gekriegt nach einem Tag.
Also das muss ich sagen, ich war
echt begeistert von dieser AliExpress-Geschichte.
Perfekt.
Also ging einfacher
als bei Paypal Käuferschutz.
Ich musste erst mal 70 Euro Zoll
zahlen. Da wusste ich schon, dass kommt.
Okay, die Chinesen haben es verkackt.
70 Euro Zoll, das ist
wenn die China-Shops es nicht checken,
dass sie das über Spanien
oder so schicken müssen.
Aber gut, jetzt haben wir
70 Euro, das heißt, der hat
wirklich 420 bezahlt.
Handkey
Apollo PC Case
MVP natürlich,
der MVP.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Ich habe einen bösen Verdacht.
Das, was ich hier sehe,
das kommt mir vom letzten Video
extrem bekannt vor.
Aber jetzt werde ich mich nicht
überlegen, was Handkey sein soll.
Handkey Apollo, das ist
nicht das Produkt, was ich bei Amazon gesehen habe.
Also hier war nichts mit Handkey
und Apollo MVP zu sehen.
Also insgesamt habe ich jetzt
für dieses Teil glatte 420 Euro gezahlt.
Also Amazon plus...
Ich frage mich, was er überhaupt erwartet hat.
Naja, er hat ehrlich gesagt, tippe
ich mal drauf, genau das gehofft,
dass er ein gutes Video draus machen kann.
Aber man kann
sagen wir mal so, man könnte eigentlich schon erwarten,
dass man zumindest das bekommt, was man bestellt hat.
Das ist einfach das gleiche Gehäuse, wie beim letzten Mal.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach so richtig
Omega Trash dieses Gehäuse.
Ja, mal auspacken und schauen.
Okay, schon mal sehr, sehr gut.
Ich fühle mich nicht ganz so sehr verarscht.
Die Lüfter sind dabei. Es sind auf jeden Fall schon mal RGB-Lüfter dabei.
Also es kann schon
nicht ganz so schlecht werden.
Genau so stelle ich mir das übrigens vor, wenn ich eine
Excelente Verpackung kaufe, dann ist die Verpackung
keine Verpackung überhaupt.
Das ist doch einfach genau das
gleiche Gehäuse, oder?
Mehr Lüfter.
400 Euro für ein Crap-Gehäuse
und ein paar Lüfter dabei. Super.
Okay, wir haben also
Handkey RGB-Lüfter.
Handkey?
Die weltbekannte
Marke Handkey?
Das ist mal wieder die Marke, die wir schon auf der
Gehäusevorpackung hatten.
Es ist einfach genau das gleiche Gehäuse.
Es ist genau
das gleiche Teil. Ich fasse es nicht.
Tja, gut.
Das ist ja voll auszugehen. Für ihn ist es gut.
Er kann auch ein Video machen.
Diesen MVP Apollo Schriftzug bin ich natürlich bereit
einen Aufpreis von 250 Euro
zu bezahlen. Das ist absolut okay.
Mit diesem wunderschönen Handkey-Logo unten drauf.
Ich wollte auch schon immer ein Gehäuse
mit Handkey-Logo.
Der RGB-Lüfter ist auch lustig.
Also es ist ja irgendwie
ein RGB-Lüfter.
Wenn wir hinten drauf schauen, ich verstehe zwar nichts,
weil es alles chinesisch ist, aber ich würde
mal sagen, weiß, grün, blau,
rot, RGB. Würde ich auch so sagen.
Die Frage ist,
wie steuert man es?
Ich meine,
ich habe nur den 3-Pin-Lüfter-Anschluss.
Wait a minute.
Da ist kein RGB-Anschlusskabel drin.
Der Lüfter ist schon lustig.
Also er sieht
echt nicht schlecht aus, muss ich sagen.
Es war schade, dass man die Farbe nicht einstellen kann.
Angeblich kann man noch die Farbe einstellen.
Das finde ich dann echt ganz ordentlich.
Das sieht ganz schick aus.
Das ist halt wirklich
der wahre RGB-Lüfter.
RGB-Konfigurierbar.
Only. Genau.
Das ist einfach RGB-Only.
Einfach immer so.
Mich würde interessieren, was so ein Lüfter kostet in der Herstellung.
Vielleicht 2-3 Dollar.
Vielleicht noch weniger.
Oh Mann ey.
Die Katze im Hintergrund.
Achso. Perfekt.
Oh.
Der gute alte Molex-Klassiker.
Was ich mich
jetzt allerdings frage ist, wenn
dieses Gehäuse anscheinend so häufig überall unterwegs
ist, was kostet
dieses Gehäuse wirklich und wo kommt das eigentlich her?
AliExpress bestellen.
AliExpress ist wahrscheinlich auch einfach so
OEM-Marke von Alternate vielleicht.
Ich weiß es gar nicht, weil die das hauptsächlich verticken.
Vielleicht ist es auch nicht von Alternate.
Ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber
die haben das Gehäuse safe nicht gemacht.
Die haben das einfach nur eingekauft und deswegen
werde ich mich jetzt mal ein bisschen
durch Alibaba
durchforsten und dann schauen wir mal, was wir da
finden können. Es scheint jetzt zumindest mal nicht
so schwer zu sein. Ich habe jetzt hier oben
bei Alibaba einfach mal
Computer Case Window eingegeben.
Jawoll. Das nahelegenste. Keine Ahnung.
Direkt bei der richtigen Seite geguckt.
Da ist es doch.
Ja, da haben wir auf jeden Fall den ersten Treffer.
Die sind sogar genau die gleichen Produktbilder,
wie sie bei Amazon verwendet wurden.
Wie hieß die Marke nochmal? Hunt? Hunter?
Ich habe es schon wieder verdrängt. Handlink oder so.
Wenn ich jetzt hier einfach mal
schaue. Handkey. Handkey.
Also da sind wir schon. Wenn ich jetzt 10
Gehäuse kaufen würde, dann würde ich 490
Dollar dafür bezahlen. Für 10.
Ja, da habe ich noch mal weitere 15 Minuten
investiert und ich glaube,
es ist auf jeden Fall ein größerer Händler
für dieses Gehäuse. Ich würde mich jetzt nicht darauf
erinnern, dass die das Teil produzieren, aber der Preis
ist schon mal verdächtig niedrig auf jeden Fall.
Ah, du kannst auch. Guck mal.
Du kannst auch
635 Gehäuse kaufen.
Du zahlst bloß 34 Dollar.
Lieferant hatte das Teil auch mehrfach gelistet.
Und ja.
Da sind wir bei 35.
Was willst du mit der Raspberry Pi machen?
JT1337.
Ich bin jetzt letztendlich auf einer Seite gelandet, die heißt
JNP Tech. JNP Tech wahrscheinlich.
Oh ja, das sieht das sehr vertrauenserweckend aus.
Schöne Gehäuse.
C701 nennen die das.
Bei den Chinesen wieder.
Ich habe damit auch einen Namen gefunden,
der verdächtig deutsch klingt und zwar
Alexander Weise.
Ja.
CRS, C-Wild, Computex, also sie stellen
anscheinend auch überall aus.
Ich glaube, dieser Kerl hier
könnte dieser Alexander Weise sein, also diesen Namen.
Mit den Messegrills am Start.
Dieses Logo, das dahinter ist,
das habe ich in Verbindung mit diesem Namen auf
mehreren Produktbildern gefunden.
Mir sagt der aber nichts, also
trotz, dass ich das jetzt schon lange mache.
Ja, dementsprechend wäre ich aber auch
vorsichtig, ob das jetzt wirklich eine Factory ist oder
ob die einfach einfach nur Bilder reinbauen.
Das machen die übrigens, das machen die
mega gerne.
Die haben auf AliExpress
haben die auch öfters Links zum Hersteller
oder hier irgendwie unsere
was die gerne machen ist so
High Quality und dann zeigen
sie ein Bild von irgendeinem Typ, der das gerade
zusammenlötet.
Verdächtig ist nur, dass der Typ
der das gerade zusammenlötet irgendwie
500 Produkte auf AliExpress angeblich
zusammenlötet auf dem gleichen Bild.
Also
AliExpress sehen ja die Produktzeiten ein bisschen
aus wie bei Ebay und
du hast dann
es gibt total oft, wenn du bei AliExpress sagen
wir mal irgendeinen, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob ich jetzt auf die Schnelle
was finde, wenn du nach irgendwie
Elektronik Sachen suchst und
du scrollst dann die Produktbeschreibung
durch, dann hast du oftmals hier Bilder
drinne von der angeblichen Fabrik
und da sitzt dann ein Typ
da sitzt dann ein Typ mit einem
Lötkolben da und lötet in der Fabrik irgendwie rum
und dieses Foto hast du dann bei 20
20.000 Produkten
ich finde jetzt gerade nichts
immer der gleiche Typ, immer
die gleiche Fabrik
also das machen die China Shops
extrem gerne
Bilder von der Fabrik rein zu posten, die
mit dem eigentlichen Produkt überhaupt nichts
zu tun haben
einballern und dann letztendlich
doch wieder einfach nur irgendwo
China abklappern und irgendwo die Gehäuse
dann kaufen. Würdest gerne
VPN laufen lassen.
Das ist ein guter Anwendungszweck dafür.
Das habe ich jetzt rausbekommen in 30
Minuten. Und ich würde dir WireGuard
empfehlen, weil es ein bisschen easier zu einzurichten
ist, aber OpenVPN tut es auch.
Stimmt, da kann ich jetzt aber im Stream
wirklich nichts zu sagen. Recherche und
Verdächtig. Also hier
die Namen, die wir hier sehen
die sind auch die gleichen wie bei Intertech.
Interessant. Ganz viele von euch
hatten auch unter das erste Video drunter geschrieben
Schau dir das Thalius Kronos an.
Das hatte ich auch damals schon bestellt, weil das
bei Amazon auch sehr, sehr einfach aufzufinden war
wenn man OFDynamic eingegeben hat
war das quasi der dritte oder vierte Vorschlag
und das haben wir auch schon da
und ich habe da eine Befürchtung. Ja
eigentlich wollte ich mir das fürs nächste Video aufgeben
aber
es sieht einfach schon wieder so
verdächtig nach dem gleichen Design aus
auch wenn dieser
Ok das ist nicht Handkey
wenigstens nicht Handkey, aber es ist genau das gleiche
es sieht echt gut aus
die sieht nicht so absolut
kranzig aus
wie so ein komischer Haufen wie das letzte
Sebaro, der Cutemon ist wieder am Start
nice, 20
Monate Sebaro, Dankeschön für den Sub
Ich hoffe es ist alles
in Ordnung, du hast deine Prüfung
erfolgreich überstanden
anscheinend sind auch RGB Lüfter dabei
RGB Lüfter
ja
ich würd sagen packen wir das
noch kurz aus. Nächste Woche
sieht das nicht komplett nach Trash aus, wenn wir das hier aufmachen
schonmal gut
wer hätte es gedacht
gleiches Gehäuse
wo sind meine Lüfter? Da sind nur 3
Lüfter drin. Reicht doch
was soll das?
das sind auch andere Lüfter oder?
es sind 3 Lüfter gelistet
ich mein hier haben sie 9
ey jetzt mal ohne Scheiß
man kanns auch übertreiben mit Lüftern oder?
ich mein 9 Lüfter
es ist ja irgendwann mal gut
im Ende wirklich wenn man das
für 133 Euro kauft
nee, einfach nur nein
ja jetzt wo ich die ganzen Produktbilder
auch genauer nochmal angeschaut habe
ärgere ich mich auch so ein bisschen über mich selber, weil eigentlich
ist es vollkommen offensichtlich, dass es das gleiche Gehäuse ist
ich gehe davon aus
ich mache ja auch schon ein bisschen seit einer Weile
YouTube-Stells, seit
paar Jahre vielleicht nicht so aktiv mehr, aber
ich gehe davon aus, er wusste das
dass auch absolut nichts verwerfliches
und hat gehofft, er kann ein gutes Video
draus machen
genau zu informieren und das bezahlen wir dann natürlich
aber so ist es eben
trotzdem, wir haben die Gehäuse bestellt
die im Discord eingesendet wurden und
damit denke ich mal, dass dieses Thema
fast erledigt ist, wir haben noch
achso, das ging über Discord
das Metallic Gear glaube ich, also dieser
Phanteks Nachbau, das haben wir noch
für ein Video, das machen wir dann aber extra
ich weiß leider nicht mehr, wer das war
irgendein Kommentar kann ich mich noch erinnern
im letzten Video, da hat einer gesagt, er hat dieses
Gehäuse, ich finde es ultra lustig, dass demjenigen
nicht aufgefallen ist, dass er genau
das gleiche Gehäuse hat, wie das was wir letztes Mal wo
gestellt haben und...
es schreiben auch viele Leute einfach dummes Zeug in die Kommentare
wahrscheinlich hat das gar nichts
auf dem Fall für diese Preise, wie gesagt
als Intertech gelabelt mit
80€ ist das ja ok, es ist nicht das beste
Gehäuse und für 80€
ist das ok, das ist nicht absolut
Trash, aber 130€
bzw. 420€
oder das andere
ich spar mir das Review von diesen
Gehäusen und
verschenke die oder sowas
absolute Geldverschwendung
ich danke euch fürs zuschauen
Tschau tschau
die gibt
ah sieben
sieben compact
kostet
define sieben
ok 100€, warum genau
sollte ich mir dieses andere Zeug kaufen
das ist ein bisschen billig
100€
das gibt es mit Case
und ohne Case, ich bilde mir an das ist ein bisschen billig
das hat ein bisschen mehr gekostet sonst
ja eher sowas in der Größenordnung
160 kommt eh hin
wenn ich doch so ein geiles Case für
160 oder 180 kriegen kann
warum will ich überhaupt ein anderes Case
haben? also warum will ich
überhaupt so ein ultra
teures
keine Ahnung 300€ Case
oder so
RGB
ja aber sag mal so wenn ich RGB
Lüfter haben will kann ich hier auch rein machen
wenn man es kann, exellent
das wird es wahrscheinlich sein ja
was ist das Internet ZTF
das gucken wir jetzt
ich muss jetzt wissen wie man sich
per Modem in das Internet einwählt
also ungefähr auf dem Stand ist unsere
Bundesregierung glaube ich im Kopf
weiter gehts nicht mehr
Moin jawoll
die passende Fernsehbegrüßung
was ist das Internet überhaupt?
das ist das Schlimme ist dass die Frage
heute eins zu eins genau so gestellt werden könnte
sag mal was ist
was ist das Internet überhaupt?
was ist Alter was ist
das Internet?
einfach Antwort ist bestimmt erwünscht
das Internet ist im Prinzip ein Verbund
von Rechnern weltweit
angeschlossen sind circa
schätzt man 40 Millionen Anwender
doch so viele
ok damals
nicht aus Deutschland
das stimmt
das stimmt doch damals schon nicht
du musstest doch
für ähm
du musstest doch Call by Call Sachen machen
du musstest Telefongebühren bezahlen
und Internet Provider
oder war das da schon nicht mehr so?
normalerweise hast du doppelt
bezahlt
das ist richtig
ein Telefon braucht man
das ist so eine typische Antwort ich habe keine Ahnung
wovon du sprichst
das ist richtig
Alter richtig
ist ja kein Plan
aber vor allen Dingen braucht man einen PC
was braucht man denn noch dazu um ins Internet
reinzukommen? was die Hardware betrifft
braucht man einen Computer
exquisite Notebook
gibt es in verschiedensten Formen einen Modem
wait a minute warum ist das Video eigentlich
16 zu 9?
und das ist wirklich
echtes 16 zu 9 weil sonst
wäre das nicht rund das Logo
die haben das
von 16 zu 9 gedreht
das ist ja richtig
Bleeding Edge
das Gerät mit dem ich den Computer ans Telefonnetz anschließe
und ich brauche irgendwie so einen Telefonkabel
mit dem ich dann sag mal ist Pock like this
auch weg?
warum ist Pock like
warum sind die ganzen Emotes
weg?
Rejected?
warum?
könnt ihr mal aufhören alle Emotes
laufen zu löschen?
dann füge ich es jetzt halt
einfach über Banner Twitch TV hinzu
Stopp
Emote lösch Aktion
was soll das?
Stimmt weil es der Typ ist
mich juckt der Typ überhaupt nicht
ich finde die Emotes gut
und das ist so ein typischer Fall von es geht nach hinten los
niemand wusste
wer das ist so richtig
niemand hat sich dafür interessiert
was der für Ansichten hat
oder irgendwas kaum haben sie das
entfernt
die Pockchamp
Geschichte sind alle bei dem auf Twitter
gegangen und haben geguckt was es für ein Typ ist
und haben sich mit ihm auseinander gesetzt
hätte keinen interessiert sonst
erst als sie sie entfernt haben
wo man teilweise sieht das
komplett negativen Effekt wieder gehabt
wo sind wir stehen?
hier exzellent Modem Anschluss
ein Modem das Gerät mit dem ich den Computer
ans Telefonnetz anschließe
irgendwie so ein Telefonkabel mit dem ich dann schließe
und endlich das ganze miteinander verbinde
und dann wähle ich mich in eine Nummer ein
und dann kann ich eigentlich auch schon loslegen
Tüttüttüttüttütt
leider also jemand der einen
ich hör mit Modem Soundeffekt auf
einen Zugang zum Internet bietet, den brauche ich auch noch
damit die überhaupt ein kann
und jetzt hat er sich ja selbst widersprochen
deswegen kostet es ja auch mehr als Telefonieren
übrigens jetzt muss ich euch mal
upst jetzt hab ich sie zurückgespult
Boomer Story Time
eigentlich richtig gut wie
das hier das im Mord致rüber kommt
Boomer Storytime, damals konnte man am Sonntag, wenn man ISDN bei der Telekom hatte, umsonst
telefonieren und das heißt, du konntest am Sonntag ins Internet ohne Telefon gebühren
und sogar per ISDN Kanalbündelung und damals konntest du dann, was hat ISDN Kanalbündelung
gehabt, 12k oder so, 12,8k und ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, man konnte damals auf
Napster, also zu Zeiten als Napster noch gab, konnte man auf Napster und man konnte damals
Musik auf Napster runterladen und gleichzeitig abspielen, also sprich die Verbindung war
so schnell mit Kanalbündelung, dass man hören und downloaden gleichzeitig machen kann, also
quasi das erste Mal, wo ich Musik gestreamt habe, war Sonntag mit ISDN Kanalbündelung
über Napster, Necrozwerkstufe 1, Dankeschön für den Sub und Uriki auch, Dankeschön für
den Sub, exzellent Subscription, der Scam-Trend ist am Start und übrigens, damals, dass Napster
jemals so erfolgreich geworden ist, ist auch wieder so ein Ding gewesen, weil die Musikindustrie
das total verpennt hat, die waren ja damals noch auf dem Trip, jeder soll sich gefällig
CDs kaufen und haben rumgeheult und nein, die Downloads, keiner kauft mehr CDs und uns
entgehen Milliarden, Millionen, Billiarden, Trilliarden, ganz ganz schlimm, wo ist Papa?
Papa ist im Knast, weil er Raub kopiert hat und später sind die dann auf den Drichter
gekommen, wenn man den Leuten das zu einem halbwegs fairen Preis im Internet anbietet,
stellt euch mal vor, dann kaufen die das sogar, wer hätte das gedacht, aber da hat
die Musikindustrie ein bisschen für gebraucht. Was zum Teufel ist das für ein Link auf Aliexpress?
Handschuhautomatische Maschine Kunststoff Einweg Handschuh Herstellung, du kannst dir
für 100.000 Euro bei Aliexpress, das ist ja nice, das brauchen wir unbedingt, du kannst
dir bei Aliexpress eine Maschine für 100.000 Dollar kaufen, mit der du Einweg Handschuh
herstellen kannst, ja geil, das habe ich schon immer gebraucht. Und man bekommt 85 Euro
gratis, liefert nicht nach Germany, liefert es nach China? Ach nach China geht gar nicht.
Nach Tibet? Kann man nicht suchen danach, gibt es einfach bei Aliexpress nicht Tibet? Taiwan
gibt es. Taiwan, China, los, Taiwan hat mit China, ich finde es geil, die Chinesen, Alter,
Taiwan ist überhaupt nicht China, also außer aus chinesischer Sicht, ja. Kann man hierhin
liefern lassen, nee nirgends wohin, okay.
Mach ein Donation Goal, genau, ich brauche schon immer so eine Maskenherstellungsmaschine
wäre vielleicht gerade mehr wert als Bitcoins, als zu meinen.
Ein Internet Provider, also jemand der einem einen Zugang zum Internet bietet, den brauche
ich auch noch, damit die überhaupt rein kann ins Netz und dann kann ich mich darin tummeln.
Würde es denn sich jetzt für mich lohnen, mir Zugang zum Internet zu verschaffen, was
findet man denn da überhaupt? Oh ja, was findet man denn da? Hm, ich würde sagen,
nee, nee kann nicht sein. Damals hast du im Internet tatsächlich eher akademische wissenschaftliche
Sachen noch gefunden hauptsächlich und ich kann mich auch daran erinnern, als die ersten
Radiosender riesen Werbung gemacht haben dafür, man kann jetzt den Radiosender auch endlich
über das Internet hören, ja toll, hat damals halt keinen interessiert, aber damals gab
es auch noch BTX und solche Dinge. Nein, Belldelfin gab es damals noch nicht, Belldelfin war damals,
ich weiß nicht wie alt die ist, wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal auf der Welt.
Abnehmen wollen, aber ich kann dir mal zeigen, was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, um genauer
zu sein, der Ralf Benz von unserer Redaktion. Weiß ich nicht wie alt die ist, 23 oder so,
keine Ahnung, die gab es damals noch nicht. Mozilla Composer ist das oder? Ist das Mozilla
Composer? Ihh, es ist Word, es ist Word. Nee, das ist AOL, das ist AOL Mail. Heute gehen
die Leute auf Reddit. Die Webseiten damals, es war halt einfach
nur Image Tag, Times New Roman, Text fertig. Damals hat man das mit Tabellen gemacht und
sowas. Aber nicht zu empfangen, ganz wichtig, damals definitiv nicht zu empfangen. Das
ging noch nicht. Also Fernsehstream über Modem war vorbei. Server Room Cleanup und Battlefield.
Server Room Cleanup, Timelapse, ok. Warte, ich muss noch pinkeln, ich bin gleich wieder
da. So Leute, ich bin mal kurz auf dem Klo, gleich wieder da.
So Leute, ich bin mal kurz auf dem Klo, gleich wieder da.
So, wieder am Start. Meinung zum Walomart, ich klick den immer
durch, wenn irgendeine Wahl ansteht, aber aktuell ist da nichts. Ich finde ihn gar nicht
so schlecht, aber wirklich helfen. Also jetzt wirklich noch mal irgendwie großartig umgedacht
habe ich da nach dem Walomart eigentlich, glaub noch nie.
Ja, Platform.io ist ja im Prinzip nur so eine hilfreiche Sache. Also du kannst im Platform.io
entweder Arduino verwenden unten drunter oder ESP-IDF oder ESP-IDF mit Arduino dabei
als als Component. Im Prinzip macht es nur das Setup für dich einfacher. Die eigentlichen
Programmierdinger sind ja unabhängig, also die eigentlichen Frameworks sind ja unabhängig
von Platform.io. Hessen sind Kommunalwahlen. Echt jetzt? Ach so, ja ich hab geprieft wahlt,
ich hab Briefwahlt. Ich hab Briefwahlt, wusste gar nicht, dass das heute ist. Wollen wir
den Walomart machen nachher noch mal? Nee, in Hessen ist doch gar nichts. Hessen, Walen.
14 meins, ok, da gibt's hier nicht. Es gibt nur Rheinland-Pfeils und Bahnen-Württemberg.
Für Hessen gibt's nix, ok. Was nehmen wir? Walen-Württemberg, ok. Aber ich mach das jetzt
relativ zackig, ne. Ich brauch die passende BigBrain-Wahl-Musik-Unterlage. Ok, also.
Moin, Dennis. Also was wollen Sie hier? Start. Das Land soll allen Schülerinnen und Schülern
kostenlos, aber immerhin schreiben die Schülerinnen und Schüler nicht Schülerinnen. Da hab ich
mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht. Eigentlich find ich das ne gute Idee. Auf der anderen
Seite könnte man heute eigentlich erwarten, dass jeder sowas hat. Auf der anderen Seite
ist es dann wieder schwierig, wenn alle was unterschiedliches haben. Ich weiß nicht genau.
Schwierig. Um welche Endgeräte geht's denn? Man könnte ja auch sagen, es gibt Zuschuss
für die Leute, die es sich nicht leisten können. Immer mal neutral. Ja, gut. Im Prinzip,
wenn einer bei den Wahlen was verspricht, ist der eh komplett sinnlos. Es hat ja eh
einen riesengroßen, also wenn jetzt was Schlimmes passiert zwei Wochen vor der Wahl, wiegt das
viel gewichtiger, als wenn vor drei Jahren was passiert ist, weil die Leute sich das
nicht so lang merken können. Die sollen allen eine RTX-Karte schenken. Genau. Baden-Württemberg
ja gut, ersetzen wir das mal durch irgendwas, was mich interessiert, weil Baden-Württemberg
ist mir jetzt eigentlich ziemlich wurscht. Aber egal. Baden-Württemberg soll sich dafür
einsetzen, dass ab 2035 keine Autos mit verboten... Nö, warum? Also da stimme ich nicht zu. Die
Masse macht's. Und ich persönlich bin der Meinung bei diesem Thema, wir kommen da auch
mit Verboten nicht weiter. Es muss attraktiv sein, Elektroautos zu fahren. Verbote führt
im Endeffekt nur dazu, okay, ich darf jetzt mit meinem Auto nicht mehr in die Stadt fahren,
aber ich habe kein Elektroauto, ich muss auf die Arbeit, ich muss einkaufen, ich muss
sonst was. Also ich denke, ich denke, du musst es attraktiv machen, Elektroautos zu fahren
oder Alternativen schaffen. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Es muss ja nicht die Elektroautos
sein. Man könnte ja auch sagen, man baut den öffentlichen Nahverkehr so gut aus, dass
die Leute nicht mehr mit dem Auto, generell mit dem Auto in die Stadt fahren müssen.
Wenn man das gemacht hat und die Alternativen da sind, werden denke ich viele Leute sagen,
nö, dann fahre ich nicht mehr mit dem Auto. Ne, da stimme ich nicht zu. Das muss attraktiv
gemacht werden, ja. Ich finde es auch gut, wenn es weniger Autos in den Städten gibt
oder wenn es weniger generell weniger Umweltverschmutzung gibt, aber durch reines Verbieten erreichen
wir das nicht. Äh, wat? Moment. Was? Ein was? Ausmistkurs? Ne. Wir sollen jetzt auch von
der Schule vorgeschrieben bekommen, das günstige iPad für 600€ zu kaufen. Mein Kumpel ist
einer von vier Schülern an der Schule. Was? Hä? Moment, das gibt ne Schule mit vier Schülern?
Oder check ichs jetzt nicht? Ich finde die Idee aber das günstigste iPad zu kaufen gar
nicht so verkehrt, dann hat man ein einheitliches Gerät. Mein Kumpel ist einer von vier Kindern
an der Schule. Ah, ah, ah, aus einer Familie vier Kinder. Ach so, ok, ja ok, das, ja,
ja, verstehe ich, verstehe ich, das ist ein Problem. Also ich finde auch man könnte sich
da überlegen ob man vielleicht ein paar Zuschüsse macht oder so, schwierig, also. Aber generell
die Idee ein iPad zu holen finde ich gar nicht mal verkehrt, weil da hat man wenigstens
das gleiche Endgerät. Ok, ähm, in Baden-Württemberg soll die Mietpreisbremse abgeschafft werden.
Gut, ich bin, ich wohne nicht in Baden-Württemberg, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das die sowas haben,
ich wusste, dass sie das in, ich hab's mitbekommen, dass sie in Berlin sowas gemacht haben und
da bin ich, da bin ich auch zwiegespalten bei diesem Thema. Ähm, auf der einen Seite ja
natürlich muss dafür gesorgt werden, dass das bezahlbar ist, aber auf der anderen Seite
hab ich so meine Zweifel ob man das durch Mietpreisbremsen schafft. Ich mein, wenn man
es seit Jahrzehnten versäumt hat, äh, günstige Wohnungen zu bauen, da kann man jetzt die
Vermieter ja nicht zwingen, ähm, ihren Kram günstiger zu vermieten. Ich mein, das gehört
immer noch den Leuten. Und viele Vermieter sagen jetzt ja fast schon lieber, es hat ja
in Berlin jetzt auch nicht, zumindest das letzte Mal wo ich geguckt hab, erzählt mir
wenn ich Mist erzähle, nicht wirklich großartig dazu geführt, dass die Wohnsituation besser
geworden ist. Viele Vermieter sagen jetzt, ey, wenn ich gezwungen werde, das zu vermieten,
eventuell auch noch an Leuten wo ich nicht vermieten will, dann vermiete ich lieber gar
nicht. Also da bin ich, da bin ich zwiegespalten ob das so eine gute Idee ist. Die sollen
halt, die sollen halt günstige Häuser bauen in Frankfurt. In Frankfurt, ähm, machen
sie es so, die bauen jetzt einen komplett neuen Stadtteil in Frankfurt. Was auch dazu,
das musst du halt machen. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, ihr müsst jetzt die Wohnung,
ich mein, die haben die ja auch gekauft, ja, und ausgebaut und bezahlt und alles, ähm,
du kannst den Leuten nicht vorschreiben für was die ihr Eigentum vermieten dürfen, das
finde ich prinzipiell nicht richtig. Du musst aber dafür sorgen, dass es genug Wohnraum
in allen Klassen gibt, was sich die Leute leisten können. Das ist die Aufgabe eigentlich
von der jeweiligen Regierung in der Stadt dafür zu sorgen. Wie gesagt, in Frankfurt
bauen sie jetzt einen komplett neuen Stadtteil. Allerdings, Frankfurt hat es auch gut, weil
Frankfurt hat Geld. Wie das wollen die, die bauen einen neuen Stadtteil in Frankfurt.
Das ist Fakt. Ja, aber das dauert natürlich noch ein bisschen, ja, aber. Also, ähm, also
ich finde, ich finde das prinzipiell keine, keine gute Sache, dass man Leuten vorschreiben
darf, für was, was sie für ihr Eigentum verlangen dürfen, weil ich kann auch Scheiße verkaufen
5.000 Euro, wenn es mir jemand abnimmt, ist okay. Ja gut, das ob die Miete erschwinglich
sein wird, ist wieder was anderes, aber du musst letztendlich, du musst halt neue Häuser
bauen, die man sich leisten kann. Ja. Und in Baden-Württemberg, keine Ahnung, kenne
ich mich nicht aus, aber ich stimme der Sache eher zu, ich finde Mietpreisbremse nicht
sonderlich förderlich. Es soll wieder mehr Krankenhäuser, ja, ja, da stimme ich zu,
definitiv. Ähm, es sollten vor allem nicht nur mehr Krankenhäuser in öffentlicher Hand
sein, es sollte so, die, die gesamte Grundversorgung, meiner Meinung nach zumindest, äh, in öffentlicher
Hand sein und nicht auf Sparflamme gefahren werden. Also sprich, es hat ja auch keinen
Sinn, wenn man das öffentlich macht und, äh, kein Geld reinsteckt. Ja, also du musst
das, du musst das ordentlich, du musst, du musst da ordentlich Geld reinstecken und
das ist das Problem, was du ja auch aktuell siehst, die, die, die Versorgung, was Gesundheitssachen
angeht, ist in den letzten Jahren nicht gerade besser geworden. Was meint ihr, warum ich
öfters jetzt mal die Sachen selbst bezahle beim Arzt? Einfach, weil ich dort in annehmbarer
Zeit einen Termin kriege, der Arzt zeitförmig hat, aber auch mal was erklären kann und
nicht das Gefühl hat, wenn du länger als zwei Minuten dreißig drinnen sitzt, äh, verdient
er, macht er schon Minus an dir. Ja, also ich, ich stimme, es soll auf jeden Fall mehr Geld
ausgegeben werden. Äh, die Bahn wird im British-Polizial weiter in Körperkameras einsetzen dürfen.
Warum nicht? Ist doch gut. Hä? Steht das zur Diskussion? Klar, warum nicht? Also, du
musst doch, man muss doch kontrollieren können, was die Polizei macht und was in den Einsätzen
passiert. Okay, Leute, ich, ich bin ja nicht, also, ihr wisst, dass ich datenschutzmäßig
äh, wohl einer der restriktiveren Leuten bin, aber mit einem Polizeieinsatz das aufzunehmen
finde ich durchaus sinnvoll. Guck mal, wenn die, wenn die Polizei jetzt random einfach
irgendwie Scheiße baut, dann ist es gut, wenn das gefilmt ist und wenn jetzt irgendwie
irgendeinen Typ was anstellt, das ist auf Kamera, ist doch auch gut, ist doch für alle
Beteiligten eigentlich gut. Ja. Die 5%-Hürde bei Landtagswahlen soll, boah, keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich will die Tierschutzpartei im Landtag, also, nee, nee, keine Ahnung, ähm, ich hab,
ich, neutral, keine Ahnung. Auf allen Autobahnen in Baden-Württemberg ein generelles Tempolimit
gelten. Ich fahre kein Auto, so gut wie kein Auto, mir ist das vollkommen egal.
Ich weiß aber, dass es Untersuchungen gibt, hab ich letztens was drüber gelesen, aber
auch nur wenn sich alle dran halten, dass es zumindest das Potenzial gibt, ähm, mit
einem Tempolimit, dass die Leute tatsächlich unter dem Strich allesamt im Durchschnitt
schneller ankommen. Ähm, ich hab ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, also, ich, mich betrifft
das nicht, also, ich kann dazu wenig sagen, also, ich fahre so selten ein Auto und mit
meinem Agila, wenn ich da 120 fahre, dann denkste, das Ding fliegt gleich, gleich, gleich springt
der, der Afterburner an oder so, ähm, schwer zu sagen, also, Agila. Ich find's von der
Idee her nicht schlecht, es ist halt die Frage, wo das Tempolimit liegt, ne, weil es gibt
in Deutschland eh nur noch wenig Strecken, wo komplett kein Tempolimit ist, ich sag
mal neutral, aber hab ich mir zu wenig Gedanken bisher drüber gemacht. Empfängerinnen und
Empfänger von Arbeitslosengeld sollen auch weiterhin Leistungen gekürzt werden, wenn
sie Jobangebote ablehnen, hm. Die Sache ist die, es wird eh unglaublich viel getrickst,
was Arbeitslosenstatistik angeht und, ähm, diese ganze Arbeitslosengeldgeschichte, du
hast sicherlich Leute, die nutzen das aus, du hast aber auch Leute, die 30 Jahre gearbeitet
haben und übelst verarscht werden. Genau, Doki, denk ich auch, das kommt echt auf den,
auf den Einzelfall an. Also schwer, schwer, schwer zu sagen. Auf der anderen Seite, ich,
je nachdem was, ich weiß halt nicht, wie das läuft, ich mein, überlegt euch mal, ihr
habt 30 Jahre lang gearbeitet, werdet jetzt arbeitslos, weil in Corona euer Arbeitgeber,
sagen wir mal, pleite gegangen ist, keine, ihr habt jetzt, sagen wir, sagen wir, ihr
wart, ihr wart, na gut, Fachinformatiker hast, oder generell Informatiker hast kein
Problem. Sag mal, du hast 30 Jahre als, irgendwas ist egal, irgendwas gearbeitet, ja, äh, und
coronamäßig Arbeitgeber geht pleite und dann sollst du Spargel stechen. Wenn das jemand
ablehnt, weiß ich nicht, ob man eben dafür die Leistung kürzen soll, sollte. Ich mach
mal neutral, ich, euch wird zu wenig Gedanken zugemacht. So, in Baden-Württemberg sollen
neue Windkraftanlagen nur in einem Abstand von mindestens einem Kilometer, von wo, nee,
das ist, das, das, äh, ein Kilometer ist ganz schön, ganz schön wenig, also, ähm,
gibt es überhaupt Plätze, wo das innerhalb von einem Kilometer gebaut wird? Ich mein,
im Kilometer, da muss ja, da ist ja gar nicht freie Fläche großartig. Also, die Wohngebiete,
wo ich mir vorstelle, innerhalb von einem Kilometer, also, ob das jetzt 200 Meter näher
dran ist oder sonst wie, macht doch eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Weil Kilometer
ist ja eigentlich fast nix, ne, ja, denk ich auch. Und wenn du in der Stadt bist, wo du
quasi zwischen zwei, zwischen zwei, äh, Häuser-Blocks noch ein Windkraft hinstellen könntest, das
ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so sinnvoll. Also, ich, also, ich würde mal sagen, ich
stimme nicht zu, weil ich mir, weil ich mir denke, dort, wo man es sinnvoll bauen kann,
ist es nicht verkehrt zu bauen. Ähm, ja. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Kein Schimmer. Äh,
bei der Besetzung von, was, bei der Besetzung von Führungspositionen in landeseigenen Betrieben
soll einer, nein, da bin ich nicht dafür, ich bin dafür, dass man den nimmt, der die
beste Expertise für den Job hat. Ich weiß, dass das oftmals nicht passiert, aber es
sollte meiner Meinung nach so sein. Unabhängig davon, äh, dass man da jetzt unbedingt Männer
hinsetzt oder unbedingt Frauen oder irgendwelche Quoten einhalten muss, ähm, man sollte den
mit der besten Expertise hinsetzen. Das passiert leider nicht. Guckt euch mal an, wer jetzt
in unserer Regierung teilweise hockt und wer dort für gewisse Ressorts zuständig ist,
es ist ja nicht so, dass der, äh, der Typ, der Minister, der für Gesundheit zuständig
ist, Äh, Arzt ist oder so oder auch nur ansehend aus dem medizinischen Bereich kommt. Ähm,
also sprich, könnte man auch sagen, hey, wenn du Männer hinsetzen kannst ohne Ahnung,
dann kannst du auch Frauen ohne Ahnung hinsetzen. Mir wäre es unterm Strich allerdings viel
lieber, wenn man fähige Leute hinsetzen würde. Nee, aber ich bin, also ich mag Quoten an
sich nicht. Der konfessionelle Religionsunterricht an öffentlichen Schulen in Baden-Württemberg,
äh, also wisst ihr was ich mir denke, jeder der das machen will solls machen, ähm, aber
am liebsten wär mir es eigentlich, wenn es so eine Art Ethikunterricht verbindlich für
alle gibt. Sonderlich sinnvoll halt, für sonderlich sinn, wichtig halt ich das nicht. Wenn einer
wirklich religiös aktiv sein will, dann hat er genug andere Möglichkeiten das zu machen.
Also ich find, ich find's auch nicht sinnvoll. Die sollen Ethik, Philosophie, was auch immer
irgendwie unterrichten, aber dann verbindlich für alle. Da soll sich dann auch keiner mehr
rausreden können mit ja, aber meine, meine religiöse Einstellung lässt das nicht zu.
Ähm, genau, äh, richtig, Religionsunterricht braucht eigentlich keiner. Der freiwillige,
was der freiwillige Polizeidienst in Baden-Württemberg soll erhalten bleiben. Okay, ich wusste
gar nicht, dass es einen freiwilligen Polizeidienst gibt und ich wüsste auch nicht, was da dran
jetzt gut oder schlecht ist. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Warum nicht? Ich, keine Ahnung. Wusste
ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt. In Baden-Württemberg soll die Nutzung des öffentlichen Personals
ent, ent, ey, das ist ne Sache, die find ich geil. Meiner Meinung nach, oder was ist meine,
nee, nicht meine, also meinem Bauchgefühl nachher sollte das definitiv so sein. Die
Frage ist bloß eher, wer bezahlt den Scheiß? Ähm, ich find's auf jeden Fall ne gute Sache
und anbetrachtet, also auch, auch für Hessen, generell fänd ich das ne gute Sache. Wenn
es, äh, weil das auch in ganz Deutschland sogar wär. Also ich denk mir, wir geben
Geld für so unglaublich viel Schrott aus. Warum nicht zu spät kommen und wenigstens
nichts dafür bezahlen? Ich find's ne gute Sache. Ob man's bezahlen möchte ist einmal
dahingestellt, ich find's ne gute Sache. In Baden-Württemberg soll es mehr Gemeinschaftsschulen geben.
Was ist ne Gemeinschaftsschule? Ist das dort, wo es, ähm, quasi Realschule, Abitur, Hauptschule
zusammen gibt, oder? Sowas wie ne Gesamtschule? Weil, oder ist ne Gemeinschaftsschule was
anderes? Warte mal, Gemeinschaftsschule. Dem Kinder und Jugendlichen vom ersten bis
zum, ach, sowas ist das, das ist keine, es ist, die ist eine Variante der Gesamtschule,
also sprich, man macht Grundschule und, warum nicht? Ich find's an sich ne coole Idee,
das würde ja bedeuten, dass du von der ersten bis zur, bis zumindesten, sagen wir mal neunten
oder zehnten Klasse, mit den gleichen Leuten zusammen sein kannst. Klingt doch eigentlich
erstmal sinnvoll, aber ich hab mich mit dem Thema echt nicht beschäftigt, muss ich sagen.
Klingt eigentlich sinnvoll, ja. Was Baden-Württemberg soll sich dafür einsetzen, das ist wahrscheinlich
die AFD Frage jetzt, Baden-Württemberg soll sich dafür einsetzen, dass anerkannte Flüchtlinge
ihren Schutzstatus verlieren, wenn sie in ihr Herkunftsland reisen. Nee, warum? Also
ich mein, du kannst ja in dein Herkunftsland reisen, also mal angenommen, du kommst wirklich
aus, mal angenommen, gehen wir mal von dem Fall aus, man ist echter Flüchtling, man
ist, man ist aus irgendeinem Kriegsgebiet geflüchtet. So, sagen wir mal, es ist, keine
Ahnung, Krieg in Land X im Norden. So, im Süden ist nix, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wüsste
ich jetzt nicht, warum die da nicht hinfahren könnten. Keine Ahnung, gar nicht, fällt mir
nix zu ein. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich, wenn du wirklich fliehen musstest, weil das
ein Kriegsgebiet ist, ist halt die Frage, wo willst du wieder hin? Ja, das ist tatsächlich
eine schwierige Frage, ja. Das stimmt, da habt ihr Recht, da hab ich gar nicht dran
gedacht. Das stimmt, warum flüchtest du nicht in den Süden, wenn im Süden nix ist? Da hab
ich jetzt nicht dran gedacht, da habt ihr Recht, ja. Schwierig zu sagen. Gut, aber ich sag
mal so, wenn einer wirklich Flüchtlingsstatus hat, ich sag jetzt mal nicht jetzt das, wo
man allgemein sagt, wir haben ja eine Zeit lang quasi alle, die alle die Asylanträge
gestellt haben, alle die hier am Start waren, als Flüchtlinge bezeichnet, wenn man wirklich
mal Flüchtlinge rein im rechtlichen Sinn nimmt, also sprich, die, die den Status haben,
Flüchtling zu sein, dann würde ich nicht sagen, dass sie das aberkannt bekommen sollten,
weil dann wurde das geprüft und sie sind rechtlich verbindlich Flüchtlinge. So, ich
weiß nicht, wie lange dieser Status gilt und ich weiß auch nicht, wann der wieder aufgehoben
werden kann, aber wenn das der Fall ist, dann sollten sie es dadurch auch nicht verlieren
können. Das wurde ja dann überprüft und man sollte mal davon ausgehen, dass das dann
okay ist. Viele kriegen ja diesen Status gar nicht. Ja, also ich bleib mal bei Neutrale,
müsste ich mir noch ein bisschen mehr Gedanken drüber machen. Betriebe, die nicht ausbilden,
sollen da eine Abgabe zahlen. Nee, warum? Das ist, das ist, das ist die Entscheidung
eines jeden einzelnen Betriebs, ob die ausbilden oder nicht. Was sie allerdings nicht machen
sollten ist, sich dann drüber beschweren, dass sie keine Leute finden. Ja, das ist,
haben sie halt gelitten. Nee, aber vorschreiben darfst du es eigentlich keinem oder solltest
auch keinem benachteiligt, nur weil sie nicht ausbilden. Betriebe, die nicht ausbilden
sollten, nein. Baden-Württemberg soll zukünftig nur die ökologische Landwirtschaft fördern.
Und was fördern die sonst noch, wenn das heißt nur, nur bedeutet aktuell wird auch
andere Sachen gefördert oder was? Kein Schimmer. Die Eltern, die ihre Kinder zu Hause betreuen,
sollen dafür eine finanzielle Unterstützung vom Land erhalten. Also sprich Eltern, die
da zu Hause sind und nicht die Kinder in den Kindergarten schicken oder wie? Oder wie
ist das oder wie ist das gemeint? Also sprich, also sprich, aber die müssen doch schon, aber
die haben doch dann schon wenig. Die müssen doch schon keine Kindergartenbeiträge bezahlen.
Verstehe ich nicht. Und warum? Hä? Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Beim Ausbau der Verkehrsinfrastruktur
soll die Schiene Vorrang vor der Straße haben. Alter, warum sind das immer so Entweder-Oder-Fragen?
Warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, hey, wir müssen gucken, dass unsere Infrastruktur sinnvoller
besser ausgebaut wird. Und aktuell, also ganz im Ernst, ich finde es super, wenn die Bahn,
also wenn die Bahn ausgebaut wird, das Problem ist, dass die Bahn sackt, also sie müssen
ja mit der Schiene, mit den Schienen auch was machen. Und es ist total paradox, das
jetzt vorzuziehen, weil es wurden die letzten Jahre über Schienen abgebaut und jetzt sollen
wir sie wieder aufbauen? Du musst eigentlich beides machen. Neutral, so. In Baden-Württemberg
soll weiterhin kostenlose Deutschkurse für Zugewanderte, ja, das finde ich ist eine sinnvolle
Sache. Du musst erstmal verstehen, was hier gelabert wird, dass du hier überhaupt irgendwas
machen kannst. Also das sollte, finde ich schon, so, by the way, ich bin der Meinung,
man sollte nicht nur, ich finde, das sollte man, man hätte das anders fragen sollen.
Es sollen kostenlose Deutschkurse angeboten werden, aber ich bin der Meinung, die sollten
auch verpflichtend sein. Also sprich, wenn ich wirklich hier neu am Start bin, den jeweiligen
Status bekommen habe, dass ich hier eine Weile bleiben darf, und dann sollte man auch dafür
sorgen, dass es den Deutschkurs natürlich kostenlos gibt, aber ich finde, es sollte
auch verpflichtend sein, zumindest dran teilzunehmen. Weil, was willst du hier machen, wenn du
nichts verstehst? Du kannst ja weder arbeiten gehen, noch gescheit an irgendwelchen Interaktionen
teilnehmen, wenn du nichts hier, wenn du dich nicht kommunizieren kannst, ja. So, in Baden-Württemberg
soll das Eingeständnisministerium für digitale, Gag raid, ja, na klar, auch wenn es wahrscheinlich
nichts bringt. Das, ja, das wäre auch eine Option, verpflichtend, wenn man, okay, man
kann ja einfach irgendeinen Test machen oder so, verpflichtend, wenn man eh schon, also
wenn man keine Ahnung hat, wenn man eh schon Deutsch kann, also mal angenommen irgendwie
ein Schweizer kommt her und kann gut, dann muss er das nicht machen, ja. Aber prinzipiell
verpflichtend, verpflichtend, wenn man eben keinerlei Deutschkenntnisse hat, ja. Also
wenn die Deutschkenntnisse unter dem, quasi in diesem Sprachkurs vermittelten Basics
liegen, das finde ich schon sinnvoll, das verpflichtend zu machen. Da musst du halt
durch, da musst du dann durch, da kann es dir wirklich auch keiner beschweren, wenn
die Sache kostenlos ist. Aber wenn man sagt, okay, ich kann schon Deutsch, das ist in Ordnung,
aber du musst, du musst schon grundsätzliche Deutschbasics hier haben, dass du überhaupt
irgendwie am täglichen Leben großartig teilhaben kannst und nicht quasi in irgendeiner eigenen
Blase bleibst. Also auch der Besitz geringer Men Cannabis soll ihm, nein, die sollen das
legal machen. 420 Vape Nation, Alter. Das Mittagessen soll für alle Schülerinnen und
Schüler an bahnwürdigem Becken, bei uns an der Schule gab es nicht mal Mittagessen.
Ich weiß jetzt wieder Boomer Time. Das geht in die gleiche Richtung, wie soll man den
Leuten, soll man den Leuten Notebooks bezahlen für die Schule, Tablets. Ich, ich, ich kenne
keine Schule mit Mittagessen. Schmeckt dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Wahrscheinlich
schmeckt das scheiße. Dort wo ich Zivilinst gemacht habe, ich habe Zivilinst gemacht
in der Behindertenwerkstatt und da gab es auch eine Kantine Mittagessen und das Essen
war so dermaßen schlecht. Es war das schlechteste Essen, was ich je gegessen habe, was quasi
aus einer Küche gekommen ist, aus Deutschland. Das waren die Reste von einem Krankenhaus
Catering Service. Also die haben quasi billiges Essen fürs Krankenhaus gemacht und wir haben
die Reste davon, was heißt Reste, also nicht aus dem Abfall oder so, sondern das was übrig
geblieben ist, gab es da nicht Kantinefrass. Richtig schlecht, es war so mega, es war so
eklig, es war so abartig das Essen da. Da war aber ein Supermarkt nicht weit weg von,
ich bin dann immer dahingegangen und habe mir Mittagessen geholt. Ähm, ich mach mal
neutral. So, bei Landtagswahlen in Baden-Württemberg soll man, wie bei der Bundestagswahl zwei
Stimmen vergeben können. Man kann zwei Stimmen vergeben, für Kandidat, für Kandidat und
Partei oder wie kann man zwei Stimmen, Leute ich bin Wahlnoob, warum kann man zwei Stimmen
vergeben, was ähm, äh, Direktwahl und Partei, ahja ok. Alles klar, dann passt das. Warum
nicht? Aber ich wohne nicht in Baden-Württemberg, ich habe keinen Plan. Ob die das wollen,
aber ich finde es eine gute Idee. Da kannst du nämlich im Zweifelsfall auch, ähm, einen
Typ wählen, der dir gefällt, aber der vielleicht nicht zu der Partei gehört, die du wählen
willst. Bei den meisten wird es wahrscheinlich eh das gleiche sein, ja. Beim Bau neuer Wohnungsgebäude
soll die Einrichtung von Photovoltaikanlagen verpflichtend sein, nö. Wieder das gleiche,
wieder das gleiche. Ich bin der Meinung, wenn die Technik attraktiv ist, dann machen das
die Leute. Und es ist bei uns, es ist gerade eher so, viele Leute wollen das machen, dürfen
aber nicht, weil die Stadt sagt, oh, das ist ein Fachwerkhaus, das ist quasi Denkmal
und auf das Denkmal darfst du keine, ähm, keine Solarpanels aufs Dach machen. Das ist
quasi komplett kontraproduktiv, ja. Also ich bin nicht für verpflichtend, aber ich bin
dafür, man sollte es den Leuten einfacher machen, wenn die das haben wollen, ja. Also
sprich verpflichtend, nein, aber wenn es jemand machen möchte, dann solltest du es ihm einfach
machen. Beim Wechsel auf die weiterführende Schule
soll die Empfehlung der Grundschullehrerinnen und Grundschullehrer verbindlich sein, nö.
Nö. Find ich nicht. Also sprich, ähm, wenn meine Eltern und ich der Meinung bin, ich
soll da und da hingehen und ich will da hingehen, dann kann ich das ja zumindest mal probieren.
Wenn es eine Schule mit irgendwas, was ich aufnahme teste oder sonst was sind, dann
würde ich den packe, warum nicht. Äh, aber nein, nein, nein, auf keinen Fall, also.
Die Querdenken, was die Querdenken-Gruppierung, Moment, müsste das nicht nach aktuellem Zeitgeist
eigentlich QuerdenkerInnen heißen? Nur mal, dass wir das wenigstens korrekt machen, ja.
Ähm, also die Querdenken-Gruppierung soll weiterhin vom Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz
Berlin beobachtet werden. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Planung, was die Querdenker-Gruppierung
aktuell so macht. Ich hab von denen schon eine ganze Weile nicht mal mitbekommen.
Keine Ahnung. Was machen die aktuell so?
Baden-Württemberg soll die Studiengebühren für alle internationalen Studierenden abschaffen.
Hä? Bedeutet das jetzt, wenn ich im Ausland studieren
gehe, dann soll ich keine Studiengebühren mehr bezahlen. Muss ich denn überhaupt bezahlen?
Oder bedeutet das, dass wenn Leute aus anderen Ländern bei uns studieren, sonst noch keine
Studiengebühren? Hä, nee, warum? Also, das soll gleich für alle
gelten. Also, mal ganz im Ernst, also wenn ich studieren
gehe in Deutschland, muss Gebühren bezahlen, dann sollte jemand, der, sag mal, aus England
kommt bei uns studieren, oder aus, was weiß ich, Saudi-Arabien, oder keine Ahnung, kommt
auch Gebühren bezahlen. Warum nicht? Also ich mein, warum sollte man denn jetzt,
warum sollte man denn jetzt gerade auch noch Leute, die hier nichts bisher irgendwie einbezahlt
haben oder irgendwas gemacht haben, dann das auch noch nicht bezahlen lassen? Also, wenn
schon, sollten das alle bezahlen. Oder? Das sind andere Gebühren, okay.
Ach, für Ausländer ist es viel höher. Boah, da kenne ich mich mit dem Thema nicht
genug aus. Ach, die internationalen Zahlen mehr?
Ach so, ja gut, das kann ich aber sogar nachvollziehen, wenn ich, ich hab mir jetzt mal kurz gedacht,
also ich kann sogar verstehen, wenn internationale Studierende mehr bezahlen müssten, ich weiß
nicht, ob das so ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist, aber gehen wir mal von aus, das ist
so, dann hätte das sogar einen gewissen, einen gewissen Sinn, weil wenn jemand in Deutschland
ist und in Deutschland studiert, der bringt dann seine Kenntnisse quasi auch hier wieder
in die Wirtschaft ein. Wenn jetzt jemand aus Uzbekistan oder so kommt und hier studiert,
dann studiert er hier und ist danach höchstwahrscheinlich auch wieder woanders. Das heißt, da hat dann
zumindest die deutsche Wirtschaft nichts von. Und wie ist das denn, wie ist das denn, wenn
ich jetzt zum Beispiel, sagen wir, in die Schweiz studieren gehe, muss ich da einen
Zuschlag oder so bezahlen? Also rein, also von der Logik finde ich es eigentlich gar
nicht verkehrt, wenn die ein bisschen mehr bezahlen müssen. Ja, ja gut, nee, dann finde
ich, das macht, macht sinnvoll, klingt sinnvoll, ja. Ich meine, du bleibst, wenn du, wenn du,
wenn du hier aufwächst und hier studierst und hier weiter arbeitest, dann bringst du
deine Kenntnisse quasi auch wieder, nennen wir es mal, allgemein wohlbringend wieder
ein. Wenn du was studiert hast, machst du was sinnvolles, dann haben alle was von, wenn
du aus dem Ausland her kommst, studierst und dann wieder abzischst, dann hat, nee, dann
finde ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, dass man mehr bezahlt. So, es ist das erste Mal, dass
ich mir mit diesem Thema Gedanken mache. Okay, wir machen jetzt einfach mal, soll die
Studiengebühr für alle internationalen, machen wir mal nicht, stimme nicht zu. In
Baden-Württemberg soll jedes Landesgesetz vor der Verabschiedung auf seine Klimaverträglichkeit
hin geprüft werden. Allein jedes Gesetz und im, ja, okay, viel interessanter ist, viel
interessanter ist, was passiert denn, wenn es nicht klimaverträglich ist? Es mag ja
durchaus die ein oder anderen kurzfristigen Entscheidungen geben, die sind notwendig,
aber nicht klimaverträglich. Was machst du dann? Ich meine, wenn es beim Prüfen bleibt,
ist okay, aber wenn das dann auch Auswirkungen auf die Entscheidung hat, jetzt vielleicht
wichtig wären, schwierig zu sagen, ja. Keine Ahnung. In Baden-Württemberg soll die Polizei
auch verdachtsunabhängige Personenkontrollen durchführen dürfen. Okay, verdachtsunabhängig
bedeutet, die Polizei stellt sich in die Fußgängerzone und kontrolliert random einfach
mal Leute, die da einfach nur langlaufen, oder? Das ist doch damit gemeint, oder? Nee,
warum sollten die das machen? Wie ist es denn aktuell? Dürfen sie das aktuell? Nee, finde
ich auch nicht sinnvoll. Also, sagen wir mal so, wenn das irgendeine Demo ist, oder wenn
irgendwie eine Großveranstaltung ist und die haben irgendeine Sperre, wo du durch musst,
da dürfen sie ja eh kontrollieren. Aber verdachtsunabhängig würde bedeuten, du läufst durchs Kaufhaus
und es kommt ein Polizist auf dich zu und sagt, ja, ich will sie mal kontrollieren. Nee,
finde ich nicht sinnvoll. Ich meine, das ist ja komplett random. Und auf der anderen Seite,
ich meine, Verdacht. Ich glaube, wenn das wirklich einer drauf anlegt, kannst du doch
total easy sagen, ich habe einen Verdacht, oder? Es reicht doch schon, wenn er sagt,
sie haben ein bisschen, was weiß ich, derjenige ist ein bisschen, what the hell. Ja, ist ja
gut. Es reicht doch schon, wenn er sagt, sie haben ein bisschen geschwankt, sie sind bestimmt
besoffen. Nee. In Baden-Württemberg soll sich dafür einsetzen, dass Arbeitnehmerinnen
und Arbeitnehmer ein Recht auf Homeoffice, oh ja, das finde ich gut, da bin ich dabei,
da bin ich dabei, excellent, da bin ich dabei, wenn das verträglich ist, das finde ich gut.
Und ich bin der Meinung, es geht in viel mehr Gebieten, wenn alle Beteiligten wollen. Es
sind gerade 500, ja tatsächlich, anscheinend finden das tatsächlich, vorher waren es 380
oder so, seit dem Wahl-O-Mart sind es 500. Na gut, heute sind Wahlen und ich mache Wahl-O-Mart,
das passt ja zusammen. So, ähm, in Baden-Württemberg sollen die Sonderpädagogischen Bildungs- und
Beratungszentren, Förderschulen, verschiedene mit Behinderungen, klar, ja wie, was ist denn
die Alternative dazu? Das ist doch eigentlich gut, warum sollte man die abschaffen? Ah,
ja. Alle in normalen Schulen, das funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht, du hast doch jetzt
schon Lehrer, die nicht mehr, du hast doch jetzt schon Klassengrößen ohne Ende, du
hast doch jetzt schon Lehrer, die nicht mehr wissen, was sie, äh, was sie machen sollen,
dass sie ihre Arbeit da auf die Reihe kriegen und da kommen auf einen Schwall nochmal eine
riesen Menge Leute dabei, bloß das sind Leute, um die du dich auch nochmal, äh, verstärkt
kümmern musst, das funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht. Da müsstest du im gleichen, da müsstest
du im gleichen Zuge quasi Förderschule und normale Schule in so, in sofern, ähm, quasi
verbinden, dass du dann dort auch deutlich mehr Leute einstellst. Du müsstest, du müsstest
deutlich mehr Leute einstellen dafür und auch, ähm, sag mal so, Leute, die sich in
diesem Bereich auskennen, also müsstest quasi die Förderschule, die normale Schule irgendwie
zusammenlegen und das organisatorisch unter einen Hut bekommen. Weiß nicht, ob das so
eine gute Idee ist. Pff, auch neutral. Äh, Vermögende sollen über eine einmalige Abgabe
ein Teil der Corona bedingten Wirtschaftshilfen. Nö. Ich bezahle genug Steuern, ich will nicht
jeden Scheiß mit bezahlen müssen, ganz im Ernst. Nö. Ich, ich, mir geht's jetzt schon
auf den Sack, dass ich, ich bin eh schon der Meinung, ich bezahle zu viel Steuern. Ich
will nicht noch, ich will nicht noch mehr Zeug mit bezahlen müssen. Und die Frage ist,
was ist, was sind Vermögende? Ich mein, Spitzensteuersatz kann's nicht sein. Ich mein, ich muss Spitzensteuersatz
bezahlen und würde nicht sagen, dass ich reich bin. Du bezahlst ja schon bei einem,
bei einem, sag mal, bei einem lächerlich geringen Anteil mittlerweile, äh, Spitzensteuersatz.
Was sind Vermögende? Auf der anderen Seite gibt's, gibt's genug Vermögende, die sich
schon, sag mal so, Charity-mäßig engagieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob das, das Zwingen dazu die
beste Variante ist. Wenn du mehr als 5k auf der Bank hast, bist du vermögend. Ja, dann
müsstest du dich mit bezahlen. Ha, lull. Nö. Nein. Ich, ich bezahle genug Zeug mittlerweile
und ich sehe leider viel zu wenig, dass mit meinem Geld Dinger gemacht werden, die ich
für wichtig halte. Ich seh's nicht ein, noch mehr zu bezahlen. So, das Land soll Pflegekräfte
aus dem Ausland anwenden. Ja, warum nicht? Also beides, man sollte beides machen. Man
sollte, man sollte, ähm, das attraktiver machen, indem man die Arbeitsbedingungen verbessert,
eventuell das Gehalt verbessert, die Personalanzahl verbessert, dann wirst du sehen, das machen
auch Deutsche, äh, dann, da musst du nicht, Polen wollen glaub ich auch nicht mehr, ähm,
da musst du dann nicht sonst die irgendwo Fachkräfte anwerben, dann würden das die
Leute von hier auch wieder machen. Aber man sollte beides machen, klar, man sollte das
attraktiver machen. Man hat doch gesehen, wie bei der ganzen Corona-Geschichte schon
wieder die Leute verarscht wurden. Am Anfang wurde erzählt, ah, was weiß ich, Supermarkt-Leute,
Altenpfleger, Krankenpfleger, alles sind unsere Helden und, und gerade die Pfleger sind die
wichtigsten überhaupt und sie bekommen jetzt mehr Geld, dann war die erste Corona-Welle
vorbei und dann hat man gesagt, nee, nee, gibt, gibt doch nicht mehr Geld. Jetzt ist
die zweite Corona-Welle am Start und, ähm, jetzt heißt es wieder, oh ja, ja doch, jetzt
endlich, jetzt endlich mehr Geld und mich würde nicht wundern, wenn es jetzt wieder heißt,
nein, gebadet, gibt nicht mehr. Oh. Also ja, ich finde, sie sollten Leute auch aus dem
Ausland anwerfen, aber sie sollten auch die eigenen ordentlich bezahlen, dass sie es wieder
mehr machen wollen. Und ja, so nice das ist, wenn, wenn, äh, die Pfleger vom Krankenhaus,
äh, äh, Balkon beklatscht wurden, davon kann keiner seine Miete bezahlen. Also ja, die
sollten Leute schon anwärmen, aber die sollten das vor allem attraktiver machen. Ja. Natürlich.
Wir brauchen mehr Corona. Okay, ja, sollte. Wir sind bei allen anderen Technologiesachen
schon so weit hinten dran. Die Schweizer gehen ja auch voll ab, ne? Die Schweizer sind richtig
gut gestartet mit 5G und es gibt jetzt so eine, ich weiß nicht, ob Leute aus der Schweiz
da sind, ich hab letztens einen Artikel drüber gelesen, dass es in der Schweiz wohl eine,
ich nenn's mal Riesenbewegung gibt, äh, gegen 5G, weil das so gefährlich ist. Ich weiß
nicht, was Riesenbewegung, mag jetzt übertrieben sein, ähm, aber nicht unerheblicher Teil
an Leuten in der Schweiz, die voll gegen 5G sind. Ich hab, ich hab letztens so ein paar
drüber gelesen, dass es da, also dass es da relativ viele gibt. Bei uns gibt's ja auch
welche, aber das hält sich in Grenzen. Das Wahlalter bei Landtagswahlen soll auf 16
Jahre gesenkt werden. Ich glaube, wir haben vor ein paar Jahren schon mal den Wahl-O-Math
gemacht und da hab ich gesagt, nee, soll nicht gemacht werden, aber mittlerweile denk
ich da anders drüber. Gerade bei Landtagswahlen, wo es hier vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr
um, ähm, ja, lokaleren Bezug geht, find ich, ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn jüngere Leute
mitreden dürfen. Ich find, das ist eine sinnvolle Geschichte.
Äh, ich hab jetzt auch keine Ahnung von Politik. Das ist kein Kriterium für und ich darf trotzdem
wählen. Baden-Württemberg soll sich dafür einsetzen, dass der Schlachtprozess in Schlachthöfen...
Alter, wollen die da eine eigene Gore-Webseite machen oder wie? Live League Schlachthof oder
was soll das, soll das geben, wenn's fertig ist? Hör mal auf. Gut, ich mein, klar, was
die vorhaben, ist, äh, zu überwachen, dass das alles mit rechten Dingern zugeht, aber
der Witz ist ja, der Witz, der Witz ist ja, man muss das gar nicht mit Videoskamera überwachen.
Es gibt genug Videoaufzeichnungen davon, dass es eben nicht mit an vielen Stellen korrekten,
was heißt Ding, Ding kann man nicht sagen, dass an vielen Stellen eben nicht korrekt
das ausgeführt wird, ja. Irgendwelche Kühe, die ne halbe Stunde rumhängen und nicht richtig
auch, also richtig abadige Dinger, das gibt's ja genug sagen, aber letztendlich Interesse
wirklich groß was zu machen, hat da keiner. Neutral, so. Das Land soll sich dafür einsetzen,
dass am Stuttgarter Flughafen keine innerdeutschen... Warum nicht? Okay, was ist, was ist, warum?
Warum nicht? Ach, stimmt, die haben jetzt Stuttgart 21, die brauchen keinen Flughafen
mehr. Den gibt's ja noch nicht, ich weiß. Aber nee, warum? Also mal angenommen, mal angenommen,
ich muss ganz schnell und ich kann's mir leisten. Bitte bann, warum, was macht er denn? Ich
hab keine Ahnung, ich lese gerade den Chat nicht. Also wenn ich jetzt nichts sehe, was
schlimm ist, dann kann ich bann ich auch nicht einfach Leute. Also mal angenommen, ich kann
mir das, kann mir das, also ich vertraue da meinen Mods, die da sind. Wenn ihr der Meinung
seid, irgendjemand schrägt über die Schlänge, dann könnt ihr ihn ruhig timeouten oder wenn
es gar hat, ist auch Bann. Ich hab grad nicht die Möglichkeit den Chat da mit zu verfolgen.
So. Aber nur weil jemand kontroverse Meinungen hat, banne ich niemand. Wie gesagt, ich hab
den Chat nicht gelesen. So. Das Land soll sich dafür einsetzen, also wenn ich schnell
nach Berlin muss aus Stuttgart und ich kann mir das leisten, innerdeutsch zu fliegen und
ich muss da wirklich ultraschnell da sein, warum nicht? Wenn sich das lohnt, soll es
weiter anbieten. Es wäre, es wäre die Möglichkeit das vielleicht unattraktiver zu machen, aber
gut. So, also was kommt raus? Was ist rausgekommen? Weiter zu den, ach jetzt muss man die Parteien
auswählen, okay nimm mal die üblichen, nimm mal die üblichen. Also, Grüne, CDU, AfD,
FDP, kann man noch was auswählen? Die Piratenpartei will man noch aus, genau. Wie viele kann man
auswählen? Ganz unten? Achso, easy. Partei der Humanisten, was es alles gibt. Weiter
zu ihrem Walomatergebnis. Die Humanisten, Alter! Die Humanisten soll ich, okay alles klar.
Gut, ich kann den Baden-Württemberg eh nicht wählen, aber die Humanisten. Scheinen ordentlich
eine Partei zu sein. Was ist mit der Partei der Äxtenmenschen? Gibt's die auch? Okay.
Gesundheitsforschung, Partei für Gesundheit. Alter, was gibt's denn alles? Die Basis, die
Piraten, jawoll. Volt, okay die Grüne sind vorne mit dabei, die Partei, den letzten Walomat
den ich gemacht hab. By the way, dass die Grünen vorne mit dabei sind, wundert mich
nicht. Die Grünen versuchen nämlich aktuell, ich, wie gesagt ich bin nicht da super politisch
interessiert, aber so bisschen guck ich schon. Die Grünen machen meiner Meinung nach grad
was, dass du bei solchen Dingern eigentlich gar nicht, also die Grünen können bei solchen
Umfragen eigentlich kaum schlecht abschneiden. Weil, die sagen einfach in fast allen Bereichen
das was die Leute hören wollen. So nach dem Motto, jawoll Umweltschutz, geil machen wir.
Wirtschaft, ja geil machen wir. Was sie nicht so gut erklären können ist, wie man das alles
miteinander vereinbaren will. Ich kann natürlich zu allen beliebten Themen sagen, ja super
machen wir. Ich glaub das letzte Mal, wo ich den Walomat gemacht hab, hat die Partei gewonnen,
da hatte ich irgendwie 80% die Partei. Freie Wähler, CDU, Linke, FDP, menschliche Welt,
menschliche Welt für das Wohl und Glück, glücklich sein, das war's für mich. Und
noch den Dalai Lama-Summen auf Twitter, eine für alle Partei, 62%, ÖDP, was ist das dann,
ökologische demokratische Partei. Guck mal, das siehst du ja schon, du kannst ja fast
nicht unter 50% kommen. Interessant, also Leute, die Humanisten. Interessant. Na gut, hätten
wir das auch mal. Jetzt wird's mir aber zu big brain, das Ganze. Okay, gucken wir noch
mal schnell. Gesundheitsforschung, juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Weiter zu dem, nein, nein,
so genau will ich mir das jetzt auch nicht angucken. Kostenlose Endgeräte, okay, was
sagt die AfD zu kostenlosen Endgeräten, da mal gucken. Das sind so Dinger, die würde
man jetzt mit denen ja gar nicht in Verbindung bringen. Die Lernmittelverkehr bei digitalen
Endgeräten ist dies ein teures, aber wichtiges Anliegen. Es gilt jedoch sicherzustellen,
dass die digitalen Endgeräte auch bei der Corona-Krise, Corona-Krise hat auch damit
eigentlich gar nichts zu tun. Alter, das ist ja aber komplett random, das hat ja mit der
Frage überhaupt nichts zu tun. Okay, was sagt die Partei? Die haben auch immer tolle
Begründungen. Finanziell schwache Schüler, SchülerX, irgendwie finde ich die teilweise
lustig. SchülerX soll auch die Möglichkeit bekommen, während des Unterrichts zu zocken.
Perfekt, Partei wird gewählt, exellent. Zudem sollen die Schulen mit Wählern ausgestattet
werden, das soll schließlich an jeder Schule mit, na top. Verbrennungsmotoren, okay, Mietpreisbremse,
okay, Moment, ich würde mich mal interessieren, was die zur Frauenquote sagen. Wo war die
Frauenquote? Die ich ja, wie es formuliert war, nicht so sinnvoll fand. Ja, genau. Was
sagen die dazu? Aber wir können von Frauen nicht verlangen, schlecht bezahlte Jobs anzunehmen,
fordern wir auch eine Männerquote, exellent. Hey, in Frankreich gibt es eine Männerquote,
ich glaube in der Pariser Stadtverwaltung gibt es eine Männerquote und Abstimmung, was
für Abstimmung? Also ich glaube in der Pariser Stadtverwaltung gab es eine Männer, also
es gibt eine Männer und eine, also nicht eine Männer und eine Frauquote, eine Quote, 50-50
Quote gibt es dort und die mussten jetzt Männer einstellen, weil sie zu viele Frauen hatten
in Paris. Also es kann auch, es kann in beide Richtungen gehen, ja. So eine 50-50 Quote
finde ich an sich sinnvoller als eine einseitige Quote, wobei ich diese Quotenregelung an sich
bei vielen Sachen nicht für sinnvoll halte. Okay, und was sagt die, was sagt die AfD dazu,
die sagt wir sind Gegenquote, die Chancengleichheit für Frauen und Männer muss, gut das sehe
ich auch so. Äh, übrigens sehe ich ähnlich, Hashtag jetzt kommt gleich, kommt gleich die
als Nazi-Kicks oder irgendwie sowas, aber sehe ich tatsächlich in dem Fall ähnlich
wie die AfD, aber beste, beste, beste Begründung sind immer von der Partei. Wir glauben, dass
sich Religion und Bildung widersprechen, da muss ich der Partei Recht geben. Also es
gibt durchaus einige Big Brain Wissenschaftler, die auch religiös sind, aber oftmals ist
halt das Conträr, ja. Oh man, aber. Interessant, okay genug Walomard, Alter. Oh Leute, ich
kriege wieder Kopfweh, ich weiß nicht, ich bin schon am Start, 2.40. Ja, das Argument
finde ich ehrlich gesagt auch meistens nicht sonderlich sinnvoll, ja. Nur weil irgendjemand,
mal irgendwann zu irgendeinem Thema was gesagt hat, was nicht gut ist, heißt es nicht, dass
automatisch alles andere, was derjenige auch gesagt hat, pauschal auch immer scheiße ist.
So, Walomard ist durch, also ich habe jetzt den gemacht für Baden-Württemberg, ich mache
jetzt nicht noch den für Rheinland-Pfalz, also man muss es nicht übertreiben. Der ökologische
Weinbau, ah yes, da bin ich natürlich dafür. Okay, wir machen jetzt kurz Rheinland-Pfalz
Troll-Edition, natürlich, selbstverständlich Weinbau, exzellent, exzellent. Moment, das
hatten wir doch das gleiche, neutral. Ach nee, ich habe keinen Bock mehr jetzt, genug, genug.
Wenn du eine Partei hättest, wie würdest du sie nennen? Fivehead-Party. Q-Chat.
Free PogChamp. Oder freie Emotes für alle. Ich würde die Fivehead-Partei machen. Die
Keg-Waid-Partei ist auch nicht schlecht. Parteichamp. Kicks-FTW. Nee, also Fivehead-Party würde
ich machen. So Leute, wir gucken noch ein paar Dinge. Reacten ist ja voll angesagt. Peter
Lustig erklärt die Telekom. Nee, jetzt nicht. Die Agile-Party, ja. Was haben wir denn sonst
noch zu bieten? Den Lockpicking-Log, jawoll, den gucke ich immer gerne. Den gucke ich
immer gerne. Was? iPhone 12 Parody. Okay, mal gucken, ob das lustig ist. Solche Videos
finde ich meistens nicht lustig, aber gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal, ob das Keg-Waid oder
Keg-Way ist. Ja, stimmt. Eben war schon relativ viel Corona ins Mikrofon gepustet. Am besten,
bevor wir das gucken, am besten fand ich die Compilation von Steve Jobs so easy. Das ist
Steve Jobs easy. Compilation. Ich finde das, das gab so einen richtig geilen Zusammenschnitt,
wo er erzählt hat, so easy, so easy, incredible easy, amazingly easy, so easy und fünf Minuten
lang. War das amazing? Amazing Compilation. Ach, hier das da, oder?
Was ist das?
Really nice really well Really nice Really? Easy Better and Better and Better
Smarter and Smarter and Smarter
Better and Better and Better Really Nicely great easier great great great awesome
Really Nice Really Mode
Dann
Brother
Time
For
Well
Really
los
Klapper is
Really Really Really EZ
EZ
Hey, und by the way, das ist alles aus der gleichen Präsentation, ja?
Really great, fantastic, amazing, priceless, so beautiful, really nice.
Thank you, Jeff.
Absolutely incredible, incredible, incredible, incredible, incredible, incredible, beautiful, great, remarkable, amazing, great, beautiful, great, amazing, amazing, great, beautiful, incredible, great, incredible, great, great, just incredible...
Du siehst bei den jeweiligen Leuten, dass sie unterschiedliche Lieblingswörter haben. Bei ihm ist es eindeutig incredible!
Great! Great! Great! Really cool!
It's great! Great! Great! Really cool!
Great! Great! Great! Beautiful!
Beautiful! Incredible!
Absolutely incredible!
Amazing! Amazing! Just amazing!
Really great!
Amazing! Just incredible!
Amazing! Great!
Unbelievable!
Incredible! Incredible!
Amazing! Incredible!
Alright! That was funny!
Easy! Easy! Useful!
Oah
So
Incredible
Incredible, great, great, great
Beautiful, awesome, beautiful
Stunning, great, cool, great
Incredible, great, that's what we have
By the way, damals hast du für einen
Weiß nicht, wo die preis
Damals hast du für ein iPhone
Noch keine 1300 Euro bezahlt
Incredible, great, that's what we have for you today
Thank you for coming and
We'll see you soon
Okay, gucken wir mal das andere
Wow
Oh
Pixel Density, you can doom scroll with twice the resolution so when someone dies and gets cancelled you can scream mamma mia
What a crispy tweet. We're like super proud to announce 5G. 5G just got reamed. Useless since we're all at home on Wi-Fi forever
We're also making the incredibly brave decision to remove the charger from the box
Removing these items also means a smaller lighter iPhone box
But we can still charge you the same amount. And go ahead and cancel your PS5 pre-orders because the new iPhone has
motherfucking League of Legends. That's right, the game that everyone loves and nobody hates is finally playable on a phone the
Brauchen wir ernsthaft LOL auf mehr. Optimal gaming experience and for sure the way it was meant to be played
You won't even miss Fortnite. Remember that feud we have with Epic Games?
Of course you don't that was like eight years ago. Now a lot of you smartasses kept saying put more cameras on the back
more cameras
So we did we added a fourth camera on the back. It's right there and if you
Also mittlerweile muss man echt sagen es nimmt groteske
Ausmaße an was du für Kameras hinten an einem iPhone dranhängen oder generell an aktuellen Smartphones dranhängen hast
Use it it'll vaporize your fucking friends and family. Sieht aus wie so ein Zerran Kochfeld ja
Come don't ever mock Apple the iPhone 12 Pro is the first camera to record in Dolby Vision HDR
Which means your YouTube video essay on which animaniacs character was the most racist will really pop
It's the all-new iPhone 12 charger sold separately Wow
Okay, weil es nicht weil es nicht so ultra keckkeck weh
Was kosten das eigentlich aktuell muss man kurz muss man kurz gucke shop
Weil ich muss dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich ein neues iphone se kaufen für meine Mutter die hat nämlich noch einen
Was war das erste modell 2016
Was war das das erste modell kann das was jetzt keine updates mal kriegt
Nein nein nein nein nein nein das erste se nicht das erste iphone das erste se
Store
Hier was kostet was kosten das ganz fette mittlerweile
Ich muss mal kurz gucken wie groß ist diese Webseite überhaupt was leht was leht die denn alles bei Apple das fühlt sich ja an wie 30 gigabyte
Ach du scheiße
What the fuck das ach du Kose das hört ja keiner mehr auf
Das leht immer noch das leht immer noch
Auf das leht immer noch das leht immer noch
70 mb 70 mb für eine Webseite
Amazingly Incredible fast
Boah fuck
70 mb
Heftig okay kaufen kost
Die sind einfach agil die skalieren diagonal ja so sieht es aus so
Silber
Sagen wir das silber sieht auch nicht aus wie dies alte iphone silber oder
by the way
Warum warum gibt es das nicht mit weniger speicher speicher ist das überteuerste der überteuerste shit den es überhaupt gibt für
ein Smartphone bei 128 g ist mehr als genug
Und dazu kommt der auf preis ist absolut lächerlich ich meine guckt euch das mal an die wollen
250 euro mehr
Und jetzt kommt ja nicht von ungefähr dass der ganze kram heutzutage kein micro sd kartenslot mehr hat
Wie sollen sie 16 g version bringen ja wenn sich einer wirklich mit 16 g reicht es ok aber das wollen sie nicht
Nein
Okay
1550 und was kostet das aktuelle das das das se
Du musst für das se ausgeben
Zwar glaube ich irgendwas um 500 oder so oder 600 irgendwas
oder
Schwarz oder red schwarz
64 g
500 ist doch eigentlich ok ganz ehrlich damit kannst du alles machen was du machen willst
Größe passt es hat sogar noch einen echten knopf ich persönlich bin ja ein fan von echtem home button an den dingern
So eigentlich ok
Stimmt ihr habt recht chat das ist kein echter knopf das ist dieser fake knopf denn der so tut als wäre es ein knopf
Ne dieses dieses dieses touch fällt im gehäuse was faked ein knopf zu sein
Haben hat das ding hat das ding eigentlich noch einen klinken anschluss
Bei der way warum machen die das ding eigentlich nie von warum fotografieren die das nie von der seite
Nein
Moment ich will es mal von der seite sehen was hat es für anschlüsse
Das könnte durchaus noch einen klinken anschluss haben
Nope normalerweise waren die doch immer oben oder haben schon gerne mit dran immer nur lightning
Unten waren es unten stimmt es war unten sag mal keiner fotografiert ah hier guck mal
Also ich habe schon lange kein klinken stecker mehr angeschlossen weil ich unterwegs das bluetooth headset habe
Ich finde es aber persönlich immer noch doof
Dass das abgeschafft wurde klinken stecker so ein ding das geht seit 50 jahren
Und du kannst alles daran anschließen unter anderem auch ein paar gescheite kopfhörer was nicht jetzt was nicht unbedingt bluetooth sein muss
Ja ich weiß es geht mit dem adapter aber adapter ist halt auch dann schleppst du noch extra adapter mit
das neue arsons rock phone
Moment den kram gibt es noch
Ich kann mich noch an das erste faun erinnern von den was ein lüfter gebraucht hat oder war das das razor faun
Oder war das das razor faun mit dem lüfter
Es könnte auch das razor faun gewesen sein das was was echt lustig war wurde den lüfter dran hattest
Fan
Es gab es oder war das das arsons faun das da das meine ich mit dem lüfter
Das ist ein arsons auf jeden fall
Ja genau mit dem lüfter
Next level mobile gaming aktive kühlung für smart phone durch das waren alle
Kannst du bei aliexpress einen zusatz kühler bestellen
Das ist ein kühler
Das ist ein kühler das ist ein kühler das ist ein kühler das ist ein kühler das ist ein kühler das ist ein kühler
Oh kannst du bei aliexpress einen zusatz kühler bestellen nice nice nice
Das rock faun ok was kostet rock faun
Erstmal gucken wie groß die website ist wir raten das jetzt anhand wie viel mb wird von der webseite geladen
Ach du scheiß ja ach du scheiß ist ja noch mehr als bei apple monkeyes sind sind die noch bei sin
Fak alder 100 mb für eine webseite
Er ist mal mobile datenvolumen aufgebracht es hört nicht auf ich habe gerade die maus da bewegt warte mal wenn ich weiter scrollen
Die laden ja noch weiter wenn ich weiter scrollen
Meine güte
Und die laden sachen nach wenn ich scrollen ok wo kann man das kaufen
Schaub rock faun wo kann ich das kaufen was kostet
Fünf
Ah nur nur tausend ein schnapper
Aber ich kann mobile games am wenigsten sind 144 herz spielen das ist doch mal was
Das designe ist pains chamber ganz im herz ein handy oder ein smart phone mit lüfter
Ja ich weiß es geht auch ohne lüfter aber
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich finde die preise für aktuelle top smartphones ehe ziemlich ziemlich pains champ ich ja
Aber asus hat da eh keine keine schmerz mit oder oder asus wie es eigentlich richtig heißt
Hat da eh keine schmerz mit die haben ja auch einen monitor mit lüfter
Die haben die haben auch ein monitor mit lüfter also sprich der monist monitor ist so high high end
extrem dass der lüfter
Braucht es heißt asus nein heißt garantiert nicht aber die coolen leute sprechen es wahrscheinlich asus aus
Sebaro geht ins freie exzellent sebaro bis denn
Wir gucken jetzt noch eine runde lock picking lawyer den guckst du mal gern
Exquisite, okay, wir wissen jetzt schon was passiert der rüttelt einmal am schloss und es ist auf
Wobei das video geht vier minuten lang der okay rüttelt zweimal und das schloss ist auf
Und was ich heute für euch habe ist ein eera brand fortress euro profile cylinder das mir von calvin in den uk bestellt wurde
Awake lock picking lawyer i'll go see you later
UK.
Er hat die Schläge mitgebracht, aber ich habe sie in Tape geworfen, damit ich sie nicht
bevor ich sie auspickte.
Bevor wir das machen, muss ich sagen, dass das wirklich ein sehr schönes, rundes Package
ist.
Es macht eine gute Arbeit...
Aber sag mal, wie dick muss eigentlich deine Tür sein, dass das reinpasst?
Das ist schon so ein bisschen so eine Bunkertür, oder, dass du das reinkriegst?
Ah.
Ich schreibe mit, ich schreibe mit.
Finally, this lock includes six trap pins to help foil pickers. One, two, three on each side.
If you don't know what a trap pin is, it's essentially a small rod that drops down and
seizes the core if you attempt to turn it without the correct key inserted. If you don't know
they're in there, picking past them can be very tricky. If you do know, however, there's a
shortcut which I will show you in just a moment. But before we get to the trap pins, we need to
pick the lock open. I'm going to use a wiper insert in the bottom of the keyway as a turning tool
in this medium hook in 18 thousandths. Nothing on one, click out of two, nothing on three, four, five,
click out of six, back to the beginning, click out of one, nothing on two, three, next out lock
picking skill. Click out of five, nothing on six, back to the beginning, one, two, click out of three, nothing on four, five, click out of six, and I believe we got this open. But I can't turn the core too far, or we will engage these three trap pins. So it's now time to take out my secret weapon, which is a plug flipper.
What I'm hoping this will do is spin the core so quickly past the trap pins that they won't have enough time to drop down.
Aha. Oh, jetzt kommen die special tools.
Nice.
Wow.
And that seems to have worked out nicely. Our next obstacle is the combination of trap pin, driver pin, trap pin, and I'm concerned they'll fall into the bottom of the keyway.
What's happening?
Outplayed.
Warum überhaupt lockpicken, wer was noch aufschießen kann? Ich mein, die Amis haben da noch keine Probleme mit.
Jetzt kommt wieder, klick.
Ha, schreckt.
Stimmt, bei den Amis ist eh kein Problem, da brauchst du einfach nur eine Säge, weil du einfach durch die Hauswand sich sägen kannst.
Letztens wieder ein Video gesehen.
Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, da hab ich mir gedacht, only in Kokona Land, da hat einer gezeigt, wie er sein Haus quasi retrofitted hat mit aktueller Verkabelung.
Und ich dachte mir, das ist echt so ein typisches Ami-Video, hier, adding 10 Gigabit, das da, der erzählt, der hat ein altes Haus gekauft und er legt jetzt 10 Gigabit.
Und jetzt kommt gleich einfach die huge Kokona-Taktik.
Ich muss euch nur das Bild zeigen, oder?
Just Kokona-Things, ja? Mach das mal hier.
Hell yeah.
Ich hatte schon Probleme, ich hatte schon Probleme, das Ding hier an die Wand zu bekommen.
Ich hatte schon Probleme, die Werkzeugwand hier dran zu bekommen, weil man siehts jetzt nicht richtig, weil ich blöd fotografiert hab.
Und nein, es ist auch nicht shab, das sieht vom Winkel her so aus, weil ich hier dahinter nicht durchgekommen bin, obwohl da angeblich nix dahinter ist.
Brutal, also der Opa hat da echt messenfrobustes Haus gebaut.
Und die Amis schneiden einfach in... Moment, wo sind wir? Schneiden einfach in die Wand mit einer Säge was ran, gibt es da auch was, wo er schneidet?
So was würde ich auch gern machen bei mir.
Veraflex, ja klar, wenn schon richtig. Ich bin übrigens gerade am überlegen, das ist ja das Veratorx Set, das ist das, was mir das Weihnachtsgrill geschenkt hat vor zwei Jahren.
Ich bin ja gerade am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht den da kaufen soll.
Das Feinmechaniker Set und noch ne normalen Schraubendreher Set, aber ich hab ja schon das Elektroniker Set, das reicht eigentlich.
Und ich hab ja eigentlich auch schon zwar nicht Werra, aber ein paar andere. Eigentlich brauch ich nicht, ja.
Nee, aber eigentlich wollte ich sagen, die Wand, das war schon schwierig und die Amis, die können einfach ihre Wand in Löcher reinbohren, krasser Scheiß.
Ich mein, da ist kein Wunder, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, wenn ich ne Wand aufschneiden kann, Kabel zu verlegen. Guckt euch das mal an, mit ner Handsäge, mit einer fucking Handsäge macht er seine Wand auf.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn du mal Rage quittest und gegen die Wand trittst, ist da ein Loch in der Wand?
Also ich weiß noch, ich hab mal so nen Rage Moment und dann hab ich gegen den Kleiderschrank gehauen, das war so ein Ikea Kleiderschrank.
Einfach mit der Faust gegen den Kleiderschrank, weil es mir irgendwas aufgeregt hat und da war ein Loch drinnen. Da hängt jetzt ein Aufkleber davor, dass man das nicht sieht.
Aber das kannst du da vergessen, ja. So, exellent, ich lass mal die Mario Musik weiterlaufen. Alter, so ungefähr müsst ihr euch das vorstellen, sah das früher bei uns im Rechenzentrum auch aus.
Also in dem Providerrechtzentrum, wo ich früher gearbeitet hab, das sah ungefähr so aus. Ohne Scheiß, das sah so aus. Und manchmal, also da wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht hab, wo ich Azubi war, und manchmal haben die uns da rüber geschickt, wo ich wie gesagt als Azubi und haben gesagt, ey schließ mal XY an oder tausch mal Kabel XY.
Du hast zwanzig, dreißig Minuten gebraucht, das überhaupt zu finden, weil, und manche Kabel hatten noch Wackelkontakte, das war wirklich ganz, ganz mir.
Und du musstest dann vom Server hinten gucken, wo kommt's raus, auf welchem Patchpanel, dann musstest du wackeln am Kabel, noch ein zweiter Azubi dabei, wir haben das meistens zu zweit gemacht, der eine ist dann hinten hingegangen und hat geguckt, wo's wackelt.
Das heißt, du hast hier das Kabel verfolgt bis dahin, hast hier gewackelt, der andere hat gesehen, ah, da hinten kommt's raus, warte mal, ich zieh hier dran, hat dann hinten dran gezogen, da hast du gesehen, wo's hier rauskommt, und dann wo du hin musst, ganz, ganz furchtbar abenteuerliche Sache.
Und dass da nicht mehr dabei kaputt gegangen ist, wundert mich bis heute.
Vor allem die, die Racks sind ja zum größten Teil auch noch leer.
Ah, exzellente USVs, was denn das, W, was sind die roten Teile, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie das Ubiquiti Logo, aber wird's wahrscheinlich nicht sein, oder?
Watchguard Firewall, kenn ich nicht, ich kenn nur noch, ah, so sehen die aus, ok, es sieht wirklich ein bisschen aus wie das Ubiquiti Logo von unten, ich kenn auch Checkpoint, kennt noch jemand Checkpoint?
Das war auch so oldschool Firewall-Geschichte, ok, der erzählt was, wir hören mal kurz an, was er zu erzählen hat, was ist das für ein Boden, ist das Pappe?
Normalerweise hast du ja so einen doppelten Boden, das sieht aus wie eine Dämmung oder sowas, ah, Teppich, Teppich, Moment, Moment, Moment, das ist sein Heim-Server-Raum, ok, dann will das aber echt übertragen, das ist sein, nee, oder, wobei, wobei, nochmal, nochmal, nochmal, äh, rechten Zentrum mit Teppich, Leute,
lasst euch gesagt sein, das ist nicht so unwahrscheinlich, ich, auch noch zu der Zeit, wo ich beim Provider war, die haben einen zweiten Standort in der Innenstadt gebraucht, für Server, und die haben sich ernsthaft, die haben sich eine Wohnung gemietet, und da bist du ins rechte Zentrum reingegangen und das war Teppich drinnen,
das ist jetzt kein Scheiß, da bist du reingegangen, das war eine Wohnung, und die haben damals das Storage-System durchs Fenster mit einem Kran reingehoben, weil du es sonst nicht reinbekommen hättest, das war eine ganz normale Wohnung, wo das drin gestanden hat, und die haben das halt gebraucht, in der Stadt, für die Stadt damals auch,
das ist eigentlich, das ist eigentlich auch mal Video wert hier, mit Teppich, die Nachbarn dachten wirklich Keg-Wade, ja, das ist ein bisschen laut für den Nachbar, nee, so, so laut ist das nicht, wenn du da nicht so viel Zeug reinstellst und nicht jetzt alles hochdrehst, also die Wände reichen da schon für,
boah, aber das ist nicht bei ihm daheim, also das ist zu krass für daheim, der hat ein komplettes Rack mit irgendwelchen Dell-Servern daneben, nee, nee, das ist nicht daheim, das wäre, das wäre, und auch die Ersatzdinger, das hat er nicht daheim, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen kleinerer Technikraum, oder Mini-Az von irgendeiner Firma, das ist nicht daheim.
Wie haben die die Black-Fiber verlegt? Was ist Black-Fiber, ist Dark-Fiber und Black-Fiber das gleiche? Also Dark-Fiber sind ja quasi nicht benutzte Glasfaserkabeln, die benutzt werden für Penetzen von Standorten, na gut, bei den Amis kannst du das machen, die haben ja auch weniger Stromkosten, Keg-Wade.
Wie hieß deine Kühlung in der Wohnung aus? Klimaanlage und irgendwie halt dann Abluft irgendwohin, frag mich, weiß ich nicht, wie die das gemacht haben.
Okay, mehr Timelapse.
Okay, okay, es wird schon ordentlicher, es wird schon ordentlicher.
Nee, nee, okay, das ist definitiv nicht bei ihm daheim hier, guckt euch mal die Kabelstränge an.
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor.
Ah, ah, wird schon besser, wird schon besser, sie mussten auf jeden Fall vorher alles ausschalten, was da dran benutzt wird.
Ey, ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Chat Dell am Flame ist, so schlecht finde ich Dell gar nicht.
Okay, Warehouse, also sprich, irgendein Lager.
So, es sieht schon mal deutlich besser aus als vorher.
Ich bin auch nicht der allerordentlichste, was das angeht, wie lange hat das wohl gedauert?
Wenn du alles ausschalten kannst, geht das relativ schnell, also die 90% kriegst du relativ schnell.
Wenn du es total übertreibst mit Custom-Länge von Kabeln und alles dann auch an der Seite mit Kabelbindern und so, dann brauchst du lang für.
Das, was der da gemacht hat, ich würde mal sagen, der ist da 2, 3, 4 Stunden vielleicht mit beschäftigt.
4 Stunden, wer das alleine macht.
Wobei, das sind verdammt viele Kabel, ich würde sagen, vielleicht hat es noch ein bisschen länger gedauert.
Ich muss mal gucken, was der hinten macht, schwer zu sagen, aber 4 Stunden kann schon durchaus sein.
4 Stunden? Okay, es geht ja noch weiter. Okay, all USVs. So, zeig mal kurz. Ja, das sieht doch schon viel.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt, so wie der das verkabelt hat, das ist was, das würde ich auch machen, nämlich, die haben so die 90% Verkabelung gemacht.
Die haben es nicht übertrieben mit Custom-Kabeln und nicht alles Kabelbinder und auch nicht alles an der Seite und Custom-Länge.
Das ist in vertretbarer Zeit zu machen. Und es sei denn, du machst es halt immer so und hast ein Rechenzentrum, wo halt alles schon immer so ordentlich ist.
Ah ja, übrigens in einem Etikett so ein Label an die Kabel machen, ist auch keine schlechte Idee.
Die Verkabelung hier finde ich ganz gut. Das ist zweckmäßig und nicht unnötig Zeitraum.
Weil es gibt Leute, die fangen an und machen wirklich Custom-Länge für Server-Kabel.
Also sprich, haben wir auch mal ein Video geguckt. Die sitzen dann im Rechenzentrum mit der Krimpzange und machen sich eine extra Custom-Kabel, was auf Zentimeter so lang ist, wie es sein muss.
Das sieht dann natürlich wie geleckt aus im Rechenzentrum, aber es ist halt echt auch ganz schön Aufwand.
Wenn du das immer schon so gemacht hast und einfach nur ab und zu mal den Server anschließt, dann kannst du das so machen.
Aber wenn du sowas komplett umbaust und musst das machen, dann bist du ja eine Woche beschäftigt.
Was haben die? Warte mal, warte mal mal gucken. Ist das irgendwas?
Ist das irgendwas? Cisco kleine Cisco Kram?
Was ist denn das?
Das ist kein Uniper und das kann sein, da kenne ich das Logo nicht.
Weil die Cisco Catalyst-Dinger, die erkennst du eigentlich ganz gut an der Farbe und an der Optik.
Uniper steht links oben dran.
Das da? Ist das das Uniper-Logo?
Kein Plan.
Das da steht, das erkennt ihr?
Ernsthaft? Jetzt wollte ich mir nicht erzählen, dass ihr das erkennt.
Enhance Zoom.
Das ist immer die beste Ausrede.
Das bringe ich auf der Arbeit auch öfters.
Wenn irgendwie einer sagt und wie sieht es damit aus?
Da sage ich auch, das war nicht im Scope. Und ihr glaubt nicht, wie oft man mit dieser Antwort durchkommt.
Das ist immer top Ausrede, war nicht im Scope.
Merkt euch das, beste Ausrede war nicht im Scope.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall besser aus und sicherlich auch einfacher, da was umzumachen.
Oder sind das die AliExpress RGB-Lüfter?
Erstmal eine Heizung im Server-Rack, so mag ich das.
Das sind die Mining-Server, stimmt. Wir haben ja vorhin gesehen, 900 Watt Verbrauch, da kommt ein bisschen Wärme zusammen.
Also ich würde sagen, wir gucken jetzt noch das Battlefield-Topplay-Videos.
Das Battlefield-Topplay gucken wir jetzt noch.
Danach gehe ich was essen und dann irgendwann heute Nachmittag machen wir weiter mit dem Projekt von gestern.
Was er mit den alten Kabel gemacht hat?
Ich würde mal fast sagen, er hat die alten Kabel behalten und weiterverwendet oder?
Halt nur ordentlich verlegt.
Gut, wenn er die ausgetauscht hat, dann halt weg damit.
Warum will der G-Man meine Jords? Das triggert mich voll dieses Bild da oben.
Geh weg.
Also wir gucken jetzt noch das Battlefield-Topplay-Video und dann gehe ich ein bisschen Hunger.
Gibt Geld fürs Kupfer.
Das heißt alte Kabel, stimmt, du hast recht, man kann auch Bahnschienen klauen und zu Geld machen, habe ich gehört.
Also gibt es Leute, die klauen Bahnschienen und machen die zu Geld.
Never sub, never donated, never Wi-Fi free entertainment.
Ok.
Hello and welcome, sagt er jetzt am Anfang gleich, das sagt er immer.
Der Preis-Champ hat Probleme mit Amazon, die sperren den Preis-Champ öfters mal.
Das ist doch wieder gestellt auf dem leeren Server, Leute.
Das ist doch wieder gestellt auf dem leeren Server.
Das ist wieder krass gestellt, das Ganze, so cool es ist, aber...
Hello and welcome.
Bad Company 2 Gameplay, jetzt geht es aber los hier.
Ich erkenne auch nicht mal den Hubschrauber.
Boah, was ist denn hier mit der Map los, die ist ja voll am abkacken.
Ich habe den aktuell absichtlich leiser, weil ich laber da eh immer drüber.
Lege auf, lege los.
Ja, das ist halt...
Ja, das kommt vor und ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig geil.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, Sniper und Chat-Clips habe ich schon zu genug gesehen.
Ich mag am liebsten krasses Infanterie-Gebäsche in diesen Clips.
Ganzes Sniper und Chat-Dinger, da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Das skippe ich mal schnell.
Jetzt geht es los.
Moment hier jetzt.
Hier ist die ganze Chat-Geschichte vorbei.
Bam.
Boah.
Kommander spielt doch keiner, wirklich.
Gibt es viele Leute, die noch Commander spielen?
Gibt es die Battlefield 4 Tablet-App noch, wo man Commander auf dem Tablet spielen konnte?
Was ist mit euch los?
Das ist doch auch gestellt.
Das muss gestellt sein.
Okay, das ist geil gewesen.
Ja, der wurde von der Kiste erschlagen.
Ja, kommt vor.
Oh, PP-GA-AIM hoch drei.
Und Bewegungsunschärfe.
Das ist halt Battlefield.
Das ist Metro.
Kein Volldamage?
Alles klar, exzellent.
Okay, die Gegner sind wirklich absolut Low-Brainste.
Low-Brainigste Gegner überhaupt.
Knife-Champ.
Okay, Battlefield-Logik.
Hä?
Okay, das ist typischer Battlefield-Schwachsinn.
Es laggt?
Kann das sein, dass es einfach nur extrem laggt?
Bei dem Typ gerade?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ist es Battlefield 2, aber nein, es ist nicht.
Das ist ein Blinden-Schema.
In ganz, ganz merkwürdiger Quali.
So, jetzt zeigt man ein bisschen Gebäsche.
Direct-Impact-Granate.
Okay.
Nein.
Das kann nicht sein, das muss gestellt sein.
Also, das ist...
Oder aber, die Gegner haben einen Bug, dass sie denken, er ist aus ihrem Team.
Aber...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht möglich.
Das muss gefakt sein.
Das kann nicht sein.
Gekommens am Start wieder.
Kommt vor.
Oh, wieder Console-Grafics.
Der fliegt jetzt noch mal rein.
Das war klar.
Das war klar, als sehe ich, dass er nach links dreht.
Console-Flicker.
Doch, da ist ein Jet vorbeigeflogen.
Das war halt das Geile am Battlefield 3 und 4.
Da ist random immer so viel geiles Zeug passiert ungescriptet.
Deutscher Voice-Chat.
Zack.
Wie gesagt, ich habe so viele Chat- und Heli-Clips schon gesehen.
Ich habe da echt keinen Bock drauf.
Ich will irgendwelche nice Infanterie-Bashtinger sehen.
Es kommt halt vor, dass man da reinfliegt.
Okay, das ist mega luck, dass der da genoscopt wird aus dem Jet.
Boom.
Und der Heli.
Okay, nice.
Der war wirklich nice.
Äh.
Da war was?
Last.
Moment, diese Map spielt diese Spielmodi und sagt, das spielt noch jemand?
Bam.
Das ist ein cooler Clip.
So Clips finde ich geil.
Da siehst du, die Gegner sind nicht total in the know-hands.
Der Typ kann spielen und es ist echt intens.
Boah, was quali, ey.
Mit der Kraft.
Ist ja gut, rastet aus.
Und Schlepp.
Bam.
Und den Zweiten.
Richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig.
Und den zweiten richtig richtig richtig poggers
PS4 share quali
Warum ist die ps4 share quali eigentlich schlecht sollte die nicht gut sein die kann es direkt im game capturen
Das ist halt battlefield physics da mobile luftabwehr
Die sollen man nicht die secret tactics verraten
Die sollen man nicht die secret tactics verraten die sollen man nicht die secret tactics verraten
Ja postchamp postchamp
Jetzt
Okay, das war nice der hat es eindeutig predicted dass er lang fliegt das hat funktioniert easy
Oh, okay, der war nice der war cool
Battlefield physics das ist auch wieder gestellt auf den fast leeren server
5 rambo klicks ps4 quali
starting out with your vintage locker paint champ quali quality
spotting a bunch of enemies
I've also chucked in another bad company
Konzi konsolen spieler kappa
Oh nice die bad company zweit gekommunizieren wieder am start jawoll
Ist das die sau oder was hat er da m240 ne m60 oder ne ne g3 m3
Mg3 war das
Okay, die checken wieder nix aber richtig geile quali
Metro stellt
Ja so Clips guckst du mir gern an da geht wenigstens was ab
Da wird mit richtig gebashed alter
So muss das sein
Ja der Muscleflash in Bad Company 2 war teilweise schon extrem gerade bei den MMGs ohne Visier
Bei der Saw hast du in Bad Company 2 auch nicht wirklich was gesehen
Monka Smoke
Für Battlefield Verhältnisse ist das Aiming bei ihm echt noch ein Point kann man nicht
sagen
Echt gut
Es ist kein Taktik Shooter
Die haben vielleicht teilweise mal so ein bisschen im Marketing Material drüber gesprochen
aber das Taktik hatte das schon aber das ist ja kein Rainbow Six
Oh die Claymore alter warum liegt der da
Was waren die da
So ich muss jetzt unbedingt Hetzner antworten wegen Sponsorgeschichte sonst vergesse ich
das wieder und dann gucken gibt es demnächst gibt es demnächst Big Brain Server Placement
Und ich gehe jetzt was essen und heute Mittag machen wir noch ein bisschen das Projekt von
gestern weiter
Ich werde jetzt den Friseur raiden der ist nämlich wieder am Start
Der Frasier Raid
Da ist er spielt irgendwelche komischen MMOs wieder das spielt immer das gleiche
irgendwelche Weep MMOs
Leute wir sehen uns ich gehe jetzt was futtern bis dann C U